Tim Ferriss: I usually have a pretty good idea of
where I'm going to start these conversations and
I'm looking at this list and it's a combination
of Memento meets Forrest Gump meets globetrotting,
and I'm going to let you choose. So should we
start with — and this will be very back and forth,
we're going to fast-forward, rewind,
so we can start at any point really.
Charlie Tuna or why you paid $25,000 to
buy fuckyourself.com just to get an email
address, or Pilgrims? Where should we start?
Andrew Rosener: Whoa. All right, let's start
with Charlie Tuna because it inspires all else.
Tim Ferriss: Perfect. Who the hell or what
the hell is Charlie Tuna?
Andrew Rosener: In college,
I studied management information systems, which
was basically a hybrid of business and computer
science. I chose that because quite pragmatically
as I am, it was at that time, mid-'90s,
the highest paying job out of college. And so I
said, "Well, that's what I'm going to do." So I
did that and I started a software business and in
East Hampton as a matter of fact. And I quickly
realized that it was not what I want to do with
my life, and so I then subsequently graduated a
few months later after coming to that realization
with a degree in something I didn't want to do and
I had no idea what I was going to do with my
life. And I got a call from so-called Charlie
Tuna, a very, very close friend, somebody I would
call a mentor, and an extraordinarily unique
individual on this planet, Peter Moehrke. So I
get a call from Peter Moehrke, and Peter says,
"Do you want to come sell fish?"
Tim Ferriss: How did he get
your name or number or both?
Andrew Rosener: So Peter contacted
University of Rhode Island where I went to school.
He contacted the business school and he said,
"I'm looking for an entrepreneurial go-getter
to become my Mini-Me." And Peter wanted to
retire and he wanted to train somebody that
had not come from the seafood industry.
Tim Ferriss: That's what we
call foreshadowing, folks.
Andrew Rosener: He wanted to train somebody to
basically take over the business in his own image
and I was the chosen one. So anyways,
I basically told him to go pound sand,
and then at that point he offered me $1,000 to
come hang out with him for the day in Newport,
Rhode Island. And I did, and it was kind of like
love at first sight, we hit it off. I walked into
the office in a business suit with a tie on
and a briefcase, my resume in the briefcase,
and the secretary let me into his office, and he
had his feet up on the desk and he was blowing out
a bong hit. And he looked at me and he said, "If
you ever come in my office in a suit again, it'll
be the last time you ever come in my office."
Tim Ferriss: What was he wearing?
Andrew Rosener: He was wearing a Native American
poncho type of thing. And he's got long hair
with a ponytail and this unique beard that, I
don't know, only Peter could carry. But he's a
brilliant man. He's a Stanford grad, he's an old
hippie, and he just has a unique perspective on
the world. And I've never encountered anybody
else that sees the world the way that he does.
And I think it was probably the most important
event of my life because I'm ambitious and
I'm aggressive and I'm full of energy and
ready to go tear the ass out of the world,
but without any real direction.
Tim Ferriss: Isn't always the
weapon suited to the task?
Andrew Rosener: Absolutely
not. Absolutely not. But at that age, it's
better than nothing. And Peter was very
good at harnessing that and pointing it in
certain directions. Directions that were —
Tim Ferriss: Beneficial to Peter.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. So I went under Peter's wing
and I spent eight years in the seafood business,
the frozen seafood business. I traveled the world,
I negotiated with I couldn't even imagine the
number of different countries and the types of
people. I literally did business with some of
the worst people on earth. The fish business
is a cash business basically worldwide. And
so it lends itself to certain elements and
it was just an amazing life experience.
Tim Ferriss: So walk me through what it
looks like, let's just say your first week or
month on the job. How is the compensation set
up and what are you actually trying to do?
Andrew Rosener: So my first day on the job,
I come into the office, obviously no longer
wearing a business suit, and I sit down at my
designated desk. Now there's only about, I don't
know, at that time, four or five people. And so
I sit down at my desk and I don't know, an hour
or two later, Peter comes out of his office and
he comes over to me and I'm basically sitting
there doing nothing. I've got some reading
material that somebody's given me to look over,
and he walks over to my desk and he points at a
poster on the wall that says "Exactitude." And he
says, "Do you know what that means?" And I said,
"No." And he said, "Have you ever read the
book Atlas Shrugged?" I said, "No." He said,
"Have you ever heard of it?" I said, "No." He
says, "Do you know who Ayn Rand is?" I said, "No."
Went into his office without saying a word. Went
into his office, got a copy of Atlas Shrugged,
brought it back to me, and he said, "Go home now."
And I was like, "Wait, what are you saying?" He's
like, "Go read this book. Don't come back
in until you're done." So I literally,
I went home and I literally took about five
days to read the book. It's a big book.
Tim Ferriss: It's not a short book.
Andrew Rosener: No, it's not. It's a big book, and
it's not easy reading either. At least the first
200 pages, it's a 200-page intro. And so I read
the book, I came back in, it was kind of like a
fifth grade, what do you call that? Like a book —
Tim Ferriss: Book report?
Andrew Rosener: Book review. And I don't know, I
guess I passed. That was it. And then it was like,
"Okay, look, come with me." And he took me down
to New Bedford, Massachusetts and drove me around
to these different scallop-processing facilities.
And I met some absolutely crazy people. Amazing,
amazing people. These are just truly — to this
day, I was just actually back in Rhode Island the
end of September for a little memorial thing, and
I met up with some of these guys that I hadn't
seen in a long time. And it brought me right
back. Really just amazing people. You just don't
— I'm sure there's other industries like that,
but seafood is a really special, truly
salt-of-the-earth business and it's such a
dichotomy from the business I'm in today.
Tim Ferriss: In that boiler room,
what did exactitude mean? Why was it on the wall?
Andrew Rosener: I think it means different things
to different people. To Peter —
Tim Ferriss: To Peter.
Andrew Rosener: What it meant was
having the right information in
order to arrive at the right answer.
He did not like knee-jerk reactions.
He didn't like knee-jerk answers or imprecision.
Tim Ferriss: So once you've read Atlas Shrugged,
which I'll admit I've not read, but —
Andrew Rosener: Oh, must.
Tim Ferriss: I know. So shame unto me. Once you've
read that, you come back five days later, at that
point, is it some form of arbitrage? What is the —
Andrew Rosener: Basically.
Tim Ferriss: Business model?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah, basically.
So what's remarkable is Peter's business is
still going today. I think it's got to be 40
years now. I think it was 30 years — it's got
to be 40 years now. I think he started in 1985,
so roughly 40 years, 38 years. He doesn't own a
factory, he doesn't process, he doesn't own boats.
He's primarily scallops. There's other businesses,
but its, let's say, core business is scallops,
and all of his competition, 100 percent of
his competition, at a minimum, they own the
processing plant. Most of them own boats, most
of them have joint ventures or partnerships with
foreign processors, aquaculture, et cetera. And
despite these seeming disadvantages, Peter has
been nimble and he's kept his overhead low and
through the good times and the bad, he's just
kept that business running. And in great times —
Tim Ferriss: And is he buying and then reselling?
Andrew Rosener: Buying, putting in his packaging,
in some cases — I don't know if we want to go
into that today, but let's call it value-add.
Tim Ferriss: We can skip certain details if —
Andrew Rosener: They would say they're
value-adding and repackaging and then
reselling. And it's pure arbitrage.
Tim Ferriss: So what was the annual
turnover? And I'm going to hop to
a specific example. So what was the
annual revenues roughly when you started there?
Andrew Rosener: They were doing about seven or
eight million a year when I started.
Tim Ferriss: And how did it grow?
Andrew Rosener: So quite quickly, we realized
I was good at this game and I became the vice
president of sales. And I think when we left, we
were about 35,000,000, which is a lot of scallops.
Tim Ferriss: How do Hokkaido
scallops fit into this picture?
Andrew Rosener: So —
Tim Ferriss: Northern island
of Japan, for people who may not know.
Andrew Rosener: A couple of years in — so
basically, this is a pure sales game. So I
literally have the equivalent of a phone book,
but it's the who's who of the seafood
industry. And I'm literally making about,
I don't know, 150 calls every day. And
it's just cold calling, cold calling.
Tim Ferriss: And you're selling to
distributors, to restaurants, to —
Andrew Rosener: No, no restaurants. Primarily
distributors, other wholesalers, restaurant
supply companies, cruise lines.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Andrew Rosener: So I say no restaurants, but large
restaurant chains, which is where we're going
with this story. But a couple years in, I come
across Benihana and I call up the Fort Lauderdale
headquarters at Benihana and, "You guys want to
buy some scallops?" And it's just pure luck that
they happened to be in a transition period where
they'd been getting all of their seafood from
one company and they decided that they could get
better pricing and there was other advantages by —
Tim Ferriss: Put out a bid.
Andrew Rosener: Put out a bid for each individual
product. And so it was just great timing.
And so I had the opportunity to put in a bid,
and by any stretch of the imagination, I shouldn't
have had any chance of winning the contract. But
as fate would have it, I did my due diligence
on the buyer, and he was Nicaraguan by descent,
and he loved cigars. And Peter happened to be
a cigar connoisseur, and so he sent me to his
guy who could basically source any cigar. I said,
"Look, I'm looking for an amazing, amazing cigar
that if it happened to be from Nicaragua, might
even give me an extra edge, but something that's
going to be really wow." And he said, "I've
got a cigar for you." Now, I couldn't even
tell you what that cigar is, but it was a very
expensive, very good cigar. I got a box of them.
And so I flew down to Fort Lauderdale and I
took this guy out to dinner, and I gave him
this box of cigars. And the fact that I knew he
was from Nicaragua, the fact that I happened to
know this — I didn't actually know, but he thought
I did — this brand of cigars, it was literally,
I nailed it. And so we had an amazing dinner
and we drank way too much. And ultimately,
I made this sales pitch about Hokkaido scallops. I
said, "Look, you guys are using American scallops,
and American scallops are great. Arguably, if
you're getting them pure form, which it's very
difficult, it's the best in the world. However —
Tim Ferriss: Pure form, meaning unadulterated?
Andrew Rosener: Unadulterated,
within a couple of days.
Tim Ferriss: Not imitation
crab meat type of scallop?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. Yeah. That's
the least of your worries. It's
the value-adding part that's not so —
Tim Ferriss: You're eating Guinea pigs.
Andrew Rosener: So the interesting part of this
was basically, American scallops are graded zero
to 10, 10 to 20, 20 to 30. And that's basically
zero to 10 per pound, 10 to 20 per pound, 20 to
30 per pound. But the Japanese, as they do, grade
them much more consistently, and so it's zero
to two, two to four, four to six, six to eight,
eight to 10. And that tightness of grading makes
an enormous difference if you are a restaurant and
you're trying to calculate your plate cost. So you
want your plates to be consistent, you can't be,
"That one plate has four scallops, one plate's
got six, and oh, well, I've got this one giant
scallop, and so now my plate cost is thrown off."
So that inconsistency, and scallops are one of,
if not the most expensive per-pound protein from
the sea. And so it makes a big difference. And so
I basically made this whole pitch about, "Look,
you guys can have consistent plating, consistent
plate cost." And there was a lot more to it,
but that message resonated and it closed the
deal and I got the contract. And it literally
became our largest client, and I supplied all
of Benihana worldwide, all their scallops,
and I subsequently became basically the
world's leading expert on Hokkaido scallops.
Tim Ferriss: So was it a known
fact in the industry that Hokkaido
scallops had these advantages?
Andrew Rosener: No. Nobody cared.
Tim Ferriss: So how did you —
Andrew Rosener: Nobody cared because they
were taking the packaging that came from Japan,
and they were just repacking it into American
standards. And so it was just another source, just
like we got scallops from China, we got scallops
from Chile, from Peru. It was just another origin.
High quality but the grading wasn't a selling
point. That wasn't a known selling point.
Tim Ferriss: So what made you good? We've
spent a good amount of time together, so I
have some guesses, but rather than guess,
what do you think made you good at this job?
Andrew Rosener: I'm not afraid to sell. I
think I have to start there, is that I've just — I
took it for granted that, I don't know, "Oh, hand
me a phone book. I'm going to start making cold
calls." I'm going to get on the phone with people,
try and sell them something that they —
Tim Ferriss: Never knew they needed.
Andrew Rosener: Never knew they needed. I think
that was a big factor. And then I've got the
gift of gab. I'm rarely at a loss for words. I'm
very good at adapting to people and meeting people
where they are. Whereas I think a lot of people in
sales are trying to bring somebody over to where —
Tim Ferriss: Where they are.
Andrew Rosener: Where they
are. You got to meet the person where
they are and understand what they need,
and then craft your message and craft whatever it
is you're selling, if possible, to meet them where
they are for the need that they may not even know
they have, but you've identified. So I think that
adaptability. Peter had two nicknames for
me. "The Chameleon" was one, and "Crystal
Meth" was the other. I have an extraordinary
amount of energy and adaptability. So I guess
I think a willingness to sell without fear and
then that high energy. I think that that's —
Tim Ferriss: All right. So to tie up just
a loose end here and bring this boomerang
back to the initial question for a minute. So is
Bruce Wayne to Batman as Peter is to Charlie Tuna?
Andrew Rosener: 100 percent.
Tim Ferriss: They're one and the same?
Andrew Rosener: One and the same.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So what —
Andrew Rosener: And Charlie Tuna, he was a
squash player. Peter influenced me in ways
way beyond business. His lifestyle, I had
never seen somebody with that lifestyle.
Tim Ferriss: What was his lifestyle?
Andrew Rosener: Well, again, he's an old hippie
who had been — he was playing the long game. He
had this little business and he loved it, and
it made a couple million bucks a year every year.
And good times, he made more and bad times, maybe
made a million bucks, but it was a great business.
And he'd just been chugging along, chugging along.
He had no ambitions of scaling. I came in,
I'm fresh out of college and business school,
and I'm like, "Well, we can do this and we can
automate this and we can do a lot." And he's like,
"Look, shut up kid. Just keep chugging." And
he would take off. He'd go down to Belize for
a month and he had a chalet on the edge of
a cliff in the middle of nowhere in Gaspé,
in way up northern Canada, and he'd just go up
and hang out at this chalet and watch whales
break in the surface. And he didn't aspire for
the things — I guess at that time, you look up
to these people that you think are successful
and you think, "Wow." And you try to model the
way that they live their life or the things that
they buy or mark as trophies of their success.
And Peter didn't have any of that. He optimized
for what I would say is freedom. That's how I've
sort of digested it into my own life and what
I've modeled. He optimized for freedom. Anyways,
he got the Charlie Tuna moniker from his
squash — he was a competitive squash player,
and that was his nickname was Charlie
Tuna. And he got me into squash.
Tim Ferriss: So what are the tenets
of Charlie Tuna, or some of them?
Andrew Rosener: I actually meant to bring it
because these tenets are like mantras to me,
but it's a few sayings that either he identified
or people that he worked with or customers that
he worked with for a long time identified
as things that he would just say a lot. And
they're just these short little phrases that get
a certain point across. And he had 10 of them,
they were on the wall in the office. I've
expanded it to about 15. I still say the 10
tenets of Charlie Tuna because it just sounds
better, but it's like, "I'm not Mother Teresa;
I'm here for a profit." Because you get customers
and they're like, "Well, can you do this for me? I
really, dah, dah." And I think, "Look, I'm here
for business. If I was here to make friends,
we wouldn't be on the phone. We'd be meeting
somewhere for a beer. But I'm not Mother Teresa
and I'm here to make a profit." And unabashedly.
Or, "Don't be backwards about going forwards."
Tim Ferriss: What does that mean?
Andrew Rosener: Well, people do things in these
roundabout ways. Just be direct. Just say what you
want to say. Do what it is you want to do. Don't —
Tim Ferriss: Beat around the bush.
Andrew Rosener: Dance around it.
Don't beat around the bush. There's one,
which I literally, I've still to this day,
never understood, which was, "Don't crowd the
mourners." I don't know what that one meant.
Tim Ferriss: The mourners?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah, "Don't crowd the mourners."
Tim Ferriss: Okay. There's
still some riddles unsolved.
Andrew Rosener: That one I
never got a clear answer to.
Tim Ferriss: All right. I feel like we were
having sushi at one point and you were like,
"Something, something in the whorehouse."
Andrew Rosener: Oh, yeah. One of the better ones,
"You can't run a whorehouse without any whores."
Tim Ferriss: All right, on its face, this makes
sense, but what did that mean in the business?
Andrew Rosener: But in its original context,
it's like, if we don't have enough inventory,
we can't do business because it's an arbitrage
deal. So if I don't have what the customers —
we only have a limited pool of customers. We're
not trying to be Walmart. So if I don't have
what these people want, then I'm just losing
business. And so if you want to run a scallop
shop, you'd better have scallops. If you want
to run a domain brokerage, you'd better have the
best domains in stock, right? It makes sense.
But you'd be shocked if you look around and you
examine failures, how often that's the case that
people are trying to run a whorehouse without
any whores, because generally they're trying to
avoid risk, right? They're trying to de-risk.
Tim Ferriss: I imagine some people listening
would say, "Well, hold on a second..." I keep
wanting to call him Charlie. I guess that's
fine. But Peter ran a really —
Andrew Rosener: Tight shop.
Tim Ferriss: Tight shop. He seemed to carry much
lower overhead and fixed cost because he wasn't
virtually integrated like these competitors,
which all makes sense. So they might then extend
that to say, "Well, if you're running an arbitrage
business, could you not identify the need and then
source the inventory?" Or are you just too slow?
Andrew Rosener: Too slow.
Tim Ferriss: You've missed the window?
Andrew Rosener: Missed the window.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Andrew Rosener: Miss the
window. It's a commodity, so you don't have it,
the next call is your competition. Very little
differentiation. It's a commoditized product.
Tim Ferriss: So you must have to get pretty — I
would imagine, to make that work, and maybe I'm
imagining incorrectly, but pretty sophisticated
with forecasting and prediction and so on,
because scallops, last I checked, don't
last forever. So if you're holding inventory,
it's not like you can sell the next Christmas.
Andrew Rosener: 100 percent. I don't know how
deep down this rabbit hole you want to go,
but that was one of our superpowers was, and
another way that Peter has really influenced me
was, Peter had lived all over the world. He dodged
the Vietnam draft and went to Namibia. He's lived
all over the world and he's traveled all over
the world, literally all over, everywhere. And
he had these relationships that were just the
most absurd relationships. Everybody had crazy
nicknames. In Chile, in Peru, we had —
Tim Ferriss: Pablo the Catch.
Andrew Rosener: We had Mr.
Lucky in China, and we had —
Tim Ferriss: Mikey the Iron Wrench.
Andrew Rosener: Crazy, really. And he
just knew these people and he would
call them up and he'd just say,
"What's it looking like in Peru?" "What's
it looking like in China this year?" "What's
it looking like in Japan?" "What's it looking
like..." And every morning, that was literally
the first thing I did every single morning.
Tim Ferriss: And that's in terms of catch,
type of catch?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Or catch may
not be the right term, but —
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. A lot of these guys, they
came to appreciate Peter and his personality.
He's truly a character, and the method. But
I would make these calls, I had a list of 20
people that I would call every single day. And I
literally wrote out a report of what that person
said every single day. And I presented it to Peter
every day. And this isn't a fast-moving business.
And so generally speaking, whatever they told me
yesterday is the same thing they're telling me
today, and so it was redundant, but what it did is
it honed a whole bunch of different skills and it
caused me to build a relationship with these
people in a way that Peter had built over an
extraordinarily long period of time. And so it got
them to trust me, it got them to know who I was,
and it got them to share information with me
that they weren't sharing with other people.
And most other companies had a more local-centric
focus on supply, so they knew what the catch was
like in the North Atlantic, but they didn't know
what the imported supply was going to be from
China or from Peru or from Chile where there's
these massive aquaculture operations that just
happened to be at that time really scaling up to
match or now far surpass the domestic supply. And
that allowed us to understand where price was
going to go and to understand which part of the
market. So when you say you've got to have the
whores to run the whorehouse, you don't have to
have all of them. You just need to know that
the guy coming in the door wants a redheaded
whatever. So I need to know that the thing that's
going to be short in the market is going to be 30,
40 size scallops, 20, 30 size scallops, whatever.
I need to know what's going to be short.
Because the stuff that's going to be abundant,
I can get that readily. I will know the price
readily. I won't get caught with my pants down on
the price. And so I can do what you were saying
before, which is what we call the back-to-back.
But by having the stuff that's in short supply,
I'm going to get the business because
I'm going to have the thing they need,
even if maybe I'm going to be a nickel or
a dime higher on the other stuff that's
abundant, I'm going to be the guy that's got
the right price on the stuff they need that they
can't get from everywhere. So that was really our
superpower, was knowing where to fill the holes,
which gaps were going to give us that advantage
that would allow us to compete on the stuff we
otherwise wouldn't have been able to compete with.
Tim Ferriss: We're going to move from tuna as
in the namesake of Batman/Charlie Tuna. We're
going to move from scallops to jamón ibérico.
Andrew Rosener: It's a good segue.
Tim Ferriss: We're going
to move from food to food.
Andrew Rosener: Okay. It's a good segue.
Tim Ferriss: Where does this
fit into your life story?
Andrew Rosener: So I did a semester abroad
in Australia where I met my now-wife,
who's German. And while we were dating, playing
international love affair, she took me to Mallorca
where I had jamón ibérico, pata negra. There's
many different names for it. The Portuguese would
tell you that the pigs are raised in Portugal and
then cured in Spain. But traditionally speaking —
Tim Ferriss: With people nodding in the room.
Andrew Rosener: Traditionally speaking,
it's a Spanish ham from the black-footed pig.
And at that time, in the very early 2000s,
it was illegal to import it into the United
States. And when I tasted this with my now-wife,
I was blown away. It was the best meat I'd ever
had in my life. I couldn't believe it. And I
was like, "Why don't we have this in the United
States?" And I was in the seafood import business,
so I thought, "I'm going to import this to the
United States." Backtrack to my college days, that
was literally — the mid-'90s, it's the emergence
of the consumer internet. I took a class,
learned about the internet. I thought, "Wow,
domain names, amazing." I started registering
them because I'm hyperactive, and every time
I had had an idea, I'd get a domain for it,
not thinking that these would be valuable.
But anyways, coming back, I thought, "I'm going
to get some domains for this jamón ibérico thing,
and I'm going to set up a website and I'm going to
start importing this stuff." So I got back to the
US, and that was my intention. I discovered that
it was actually illegal. The FDA did not allow
you to import this jamón ibérico because it's
cured for 18 months. It's a raw meat that's cured
for 18 months in salt and like French cheese,
the FDA didn't designate it as fit for human
consumption. So that was that. And I put it
in the closet and forgot about it.
And then a couple years later,
I'm driving to my office and I hear on NPR radio
that George Bush is about to get the first jamón
ibérico ever legally imported into the United
States, and I couldn't believe it. And I got to
his proverbial jaw dropped. He immediately was
like, "How much do you want for those domains?"
It was the first time — like I said, I bought a
lot of domains at that point already, but never
thinking, "These are valuable assets that I'm
going to sell in the future." It was always like,
"This is another lame-brained idea that I'm going
to try and build a business around that I never
got around to." I didn't even know what to answer,
so I said, "I want one of your hams," and he goes,
"No problem, done." I was like, "Wait, that's too
easy," so I was like, "$5,000," and he's like,
"Done." I was like, "The ham's got to come from
that first container, George Bush's container,"
and he's like, "Done." I was like, "Wow,
okay." I was like, "All right, it's yours."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Andrew Rosener: I had a few
of these domains and I transferred the domains
to him on the spot, and at that time, I had no
idea how to do a domain transaction. I just took
the leap of faith, transferred him to domains,
a couple of weeks later, I got a coffin in the
mail and the rest is history. That moment then
gave birth to my whole domain business. I realized
that this little esoteric corner of the world,
if this guy wanted his domains that bad, every
business in the world is going to want or need
their respective domain names. At this point,
I'm still in the seafood business and I was
making quite a lot of money for somebody in their
mid-20s, and I just started backing up the truck
and buying as many domains as I possibly could.
Tim Ferriss: Now, where or when
does Tess Diaz into the picture?
Andrew Rosener: Tess Diaz worked for GoDaddy,
and GoDaddy, at this time, again, early 2000s,
they launched what they called "The executive
department," or something at that time. They
looked at their accounts and they were like,
"Wow, some of these people have thousands of
domain names, let's reach out to them and figure
out what they're doing with these domains," so
they set up this little department with a few
people and their job was to reach out to these
people that had more than a thousand domains and
figure out what they were doing with them. Most of
these people knew what they were doing with them,
they had a purpose. I did not. Anyways,
Tess called me and I was actually in my
car. I was driving up to my good friend JB's
house in upstate New York, Quiet Please Farm.
I had a lot of time, so she called me and she
said, "What are you doing with all these domains?"
I was like, "I have no idea. Every time I have
an idea, I buy them." She said, "There's a domain
industry and there's people trading these things
and you can monetize them." I was like, "I had no
idea, tell me more." Literally, I spent three
or four hours on the phone with her getting
a download on — that there's a domain industry
and an aftermarket and there's people on forums
talking about these things and there's different
ways to park them and monetize them and, "Google
will pay you for the clicks." This was all new to
me, but it was fascinating. I then spent weeks,
as I do, deep diving into this new world of
domain names, and I got super fascinated.
At this point, I'm married and my wife thinks
I'm crazy. In fact, everybody thinks I'm crazy,
because I've now spent a considerable
amount of money buying domain names.
Tim Ferriss: By that point?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah, by that point. Basically,
when I got married, my wife said, "Look, I'll
live in the United States for four years,
and then the shot clock is up and then we're
moving somewhere else." The shot clock ran up
and it ran up at the same time that I was doing
this deep dive into this domain world. What I
realized was there was nobody playing matchmaker
between the people that had these domains,
who were fascinating characters. Literally,
you would be hard-pressed to find an industry
that has such a motley crew of extremely
successful and a variety of standards. People,
but from just wildly different backgrounds,
wildly different interests, that have stumbled
into this industry in completely different ways.
I decided to basically build a domain brokerage
business to play matchmaker. There
was people trading amongst themselves,
playing hot potato in the domain industry, but
there was nobody taking these domain names and
selling them to the end users that ultimately
could benefit most from them. More importantly,
playing educator between this nascent asset class
and the broader business environment that I think
recognized, "This is an extension of our brand,"
but didn't understand why these things might cost
so much and why they're so valuable and the
various benefits of owning them. Therein was
born Media Options. My wife and I founded it
together, and I think it was maybe a year or
two later that Tess — Tess became my account
rep at GoDaddy, just going full circle here,
and then ultimately, left GoDaddy to come to work
for me. I went from a Lone Ranger to plus one.
Tim Ferriss: VP of sales.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. Shortly
thereafter, we moved to Panama. We
left Rhode Island and moved to Panama.
Tim Ferriss: If we take a 30,000-foot view for
a second for folks who are unfamiliar with the
domain/domaining world, and I would put myself
in that category. Maybe I know the edges of the
puzzle, but I really don't know what the entire
thing looks like at all. There's an aftermarket,
there are auctions, expiries, dnjournal.com,
dnforum.com, domainnamewire.com, expired
auctions. Can you just give us an overview of
what that world looks like? What are the main
pieces? The main positions, so to speak?
Andrew Rosener: Like any market, it has a
structure, there's a clear texture and structure
to the market. Let's say, at the lowest level,
you've got guys that just really appreciate domain
names and they're investing in domain names. Maybe
they're hoping to strike it rich like a lottery
ticket, maybe they're like me and they just have
eccentric ideas and register domains around them.
Maybe they drank too much and thought they had a
clever idea that they regret in the morning, but
there's just people that are collecting domain
names, and those are primary registrations.
Then you've got people that are really taking
it seriously, investing into domain names,
and they've got varying methodologies. I've
got one of my very good friends, Yani, is super
methodical, he's a robot. He's got algorithms.
There's very little emotion or anything that goes
into his formula, whereas I'm the opposite. I'm,
basically, 100 percent on instinct and then I back
it up with data, but I primarily am operating from
instinct. Either way, we utilize primarily the
same tools as the SEO industry to gauge what
the total addressable market of these domains is.
There's a whole bunch of different tool providers
in the domain industry to uncover who owns a
domain, trying to evaluate a domain based on
a bunch of data points. There's a bunch of
different tool providers. Then you've got
forums where these people meet. Less today,
it's less relevant today, I would say Twitter
is the — X. Another segue we can go down, but
X is really where the material domain world is
meeting these days. There's investors coming
out at this from a lot of different angles,
and then you've got some of the names that
you mentioned, Domain Name Wire, DN Journal.
I would say those are the two most prominent.
They are covering the news, these are our true
journalists for the domain name industry,
and they're talking about policy changes.
Domain names are governed by ICANN, which is the
multi-stakeholder, non-governmental organization
that basically governs domain names. Remarkably
important organization, by the way, that very few
people know even exists, and more people should
know that they exist. There's all these different
layers, and then you've got — as the industry
evolved through the late '90s and then the early
2000s, these good domain names get, what we call,
type-in traffic. It is just inherent traffic,
people just inherently go to these domain names.
Tim Ferriss: Prime.com?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah, prime.com. People want
to go to Prime at Amazon, they just type in
prime.com. We helped Amazon to get prime.com for
that very reason, because tens of thousands of
people were going to prime.com every day and
not finding Amazon. If you own these domains,
though, you can park them with Google or Yahoo
on their parking feeds and they display keyword
advertising, and then when people click them, you
earn a couple cents, sometimes more. At scale,
that can be considerable revenue, and that used to
be the primary business model in the early 2000s.
Tim Ferriss: Let's capture that traffic, hope
it leads to click-throughs on your advertising,
and then get paid by Google.
Andrew Rosener: 100 percent.
Tim Ferriss: Just out of curiosity, because I know
I'm not the only person who knows what it is now,
I'm not giving a real example, but I'm typing
something like "Google" really quickly and I
type an extra O, right? Google, three Os, and
I land on that page. How much do you think the
owners of some of these misspellings pull in?
Andrew Rosener: I'm going to pause for a second,
because this is a really important point that I
want to make. I would say, if your audience got
one point from me today, I really want it to be
this. There is a very clear distinction between a
domain investor and a domain squatter. The guy
that owns Google with three Os is a squatter,
he is the person, he, she, whatever, is the person
that gives the domain industry a bad rap in the
late '90s, in the early 2000s. That is worn off
— it still resonates, but it's mostly worn off at
this point, but in the early days of my business,
that was the biggest hurdle. Like, "You're just a
dirty domain squatter." It was a really bad — the
fact that somebody was an investor in domain names
was a negative connotation, and funny enough, some
of the biggest domain investors are famous VCs
that are funding the companies that are accusing
domain investors of being squatters. Anyways.
Tim Ferriss: Really. There are VCs who own just —
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — spreadsheets full of domains?
Andrew Rosener: More targeted, super high quality,
maybe tens of domains, but really high quality.
Tim Ferriss: Are they holding them for portfolio
companies or are they looking to —
Andrew Rosener:
I don't know, I don't know.
Tim Ferriss: Can I play stand-in
for the listeners for a second?
Andrew Rosener: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Andrew Rosener: Please, do.
Tim Ferriss: This differentiation,
I think, is important to underscore,
squatter versus investor. Do investors still
buy URLs that represent trademarks owned by
other people? If so, how is that reconciled?
Andrew Rosener: There's always going to be bad
actors, but it is a very, very, very small
fraction of what it used to be. We've got
cybersquatting laws now, it's quite punitive,
$100,000. If you get sued in federal court,
it's $100,000 per name penalty, for
infringing on somebody's trademarks,
cybersquatting. There are also much cheaper,
faster, and easier mechanisms for recovering
domain names that infringe on your trademark
called the UDRP, Universal Domain Resolution —
Tim Ferriss: Protocol?
Andrew Rosener: Protocol.
Tim Ferriss: I'm just guessing.
Andrew Rosener: I think it's
"Protocol." Basically, there's three elements,
and if you could prove those three elements,
the domain's going to immediately get transferred
to you, okay? It's only going to cost you about,
let's say, $2,500, maybe three grand if you go
for a three-person panel for this arbitration.
They're going to make a decision, the owner gets
to respond if they choose to, and in most of these
cases where it's a clear trademark infringement,
they don't even respond. Then that's it, you're
going to get to the domain name assuming they —
Tim Ferriss: You don't need to know the
identity of the holder for that.
Andrew Rosener: Nope, you don't.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Andrew Rosener: There's very
strong mechanisms both preventing and, let's
say, clearing the market. There's very little
upside to doing this anymore. Like I said,
there's still bad actors, but it's a very
small problem compared to what it used to be.
Tim Ferriss: When did you put up your shingle
and start the company?
Andrew Rosener: 2008.
Tim Ferriss: I'm no historian, but 2008
doesn't sound super early in the domain game.
Andrew Rosener: No.
Tim Ferriss: Which makes it more interesting
to me, because it's not day one of Google
AdWords where you're shooting fish in a barrel,
right? There's a point in time where it was like,
"Yeah, we can just look at the dictionary and go
buy a bunch of dictionaries."
Andrew Rosener: Totally.
Tim Ferriss: At this point, it would seem like
you are buying or matching, or both. Maybe you
could explain the business model then, what it
looked like, which is incredibly interesting,
because it raises the question of how to
value or how to determine a reasonable price,
acceptable purchase price. I wouldn't know
how to begin doing that for something like X —
Andrew Rosener: Nor would
almost anybody else like.
Tim Ferriss: Like x.com, right?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I don't know who would use it for
what. I know it's a single letter, okay. Could you
walk us through what the business model was at the
time? You're coming in, clearly not too late, but
certain low-hanging fruit. Most of the low-hanging
fruit had been, a lot of them, removed, right?
Right, so then how do you determine a fair price?
Andrew Rosener: I'm taking a wild guess here,
but just for emphasis, literally, probably 95, 98
percent of our business is domain names that were
registered prior to 2000. In 2008, when, as you
said, hung up my shingle and started the business,
I am super late to the party. Now, I
have started accumulating some domains,
but most of them weren't really great at that
point, but I understood that it was going
to be a very capital-intensive business,
and I had already spent a lot of capital,
and if I wanted to continue this hobby, I
needed to generate cashflow to support it,
okay? That was one of the premises of starting
Media Options. Then that premise worked, we
started successfully selling other people's domain
names using our commissions to then fund the
acquisition of better domain names for ourselves.
Tim Ferriss: People would come to you and say,
"I have fillintheblank.com
and I would like to sell it,
but I'm not sure how to do it."
Andrew Rosener: A line out the door.
One thing that is — there's a handful of domain
investors that understand what they've got and
they have no real eagerness or intention
to sell except when somebody makes them,
but everybody else is literally — they buy a
domain and they expect it's going to sell the
next day. Anybody that can help them achieve that
unrealistic objective, they are banging on the
door. Yes, I have literally — it could be a segue
into a million things, but let's stay here. I get
so many emails every day of people that want me to
sell their domains, so endless supply of inventory
to sell. I start banging on doors and, basically,
playing fake it until I make it, because nobody
had really done this before, so I was —
Tim Ferriss: How did people
find you at that point?
Andrew Rosener: Most of the
people that owned the domains I'm selling
at that point, that's no longer the case,
but at that point, most of the domains that
I'm selling are owned by domain investors,
so I'm meeting these people on the forums.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Andrew Rosener: There's DN Journal, which does
this weekly sales report. At that time. Today,
I'm the most discreet person you're
ever going to meet, but at that time,
trying to build a business, every time I
make a sale, I would announce that sale.
Tim Ferriss: It would get published on the forums?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. It'd get published in DN
Journal, that was a source of pride. It was like,
"Look, my sale got published in DN Journal this
week." People would see that you sold a domain for
a good price and then double down on. That was how
the people that owned the domains were finding me.
Tim Ferriss: Were finding you, got it.
Andrew Rosener: I'm finding the people
that I was trying to sell them to,
okay? Very rarely are they coming and finding
me. Did happen, right? Lightning strikes —
Tim Ferriss: Do you still remember any of your
initial sales where you're like, "Holy shit,
I think this could be a thing." Do you remember?
Andrew Rosener: The sale where I thought,
"Wow. Okay, I think I'm going
to be able to make this into
a business," was pizza.net, which —
Tim Ferriss: This is a great example,
because it seems like there are a
lot of people you could potentially
sell that to. Walk us through pizza.net then.
Andrew Rosener: Pizza.net was a unique case,
pizza.net was a very famous domain, because it was
highlighted quite prominently in the movie The Net
with Sandra Bullock in 1994.
Tim Ferriss: Really?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. This is a 1994 movie and
Sandra Bullock, first time anybody has ever seen
anybody order a pizza online on the internet.
Sandra Bullock goes to pizza.net and orders a
pizza online. Man, it's another rabbit hole, but
pizza.net actually has prior art on a whole bunch
of patents. Google has the patent on, "Here's
your IP, we're going to provide you — you search
for pizza, we're going to provide you the pizza
restaurants that are within a certain distance
around your IP address." They have a patent on
that. Pizza.net was doing that prior to Google
filing that patent, so pizza.net technically had —
Tim Ferriss: The company that owned
pizza.net was doing that type of proximity —
Andrew Rosener: Yes. Yes. The company was gone,
but the owner of the domain, which — he's also a
fascinating — that's another fascinating story,
but I don't recall how he found me.
Andrew Rosener: He was the guy that literally
strung the internet cable up the entire East Coast
of the United States. He literally put in the
actual hardware that created the first internet
network on the East Coast of the United States.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Andrew Rosener: Adam — I can't remember
his last name, but Adam something.
Tim Ferriss: We'll put it in
the show notes.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: We'll also put the rest of the tenets
of Charlie Tuna in the show notes, for people
who are wondering where those might be found.
Andrew Rosener: At the time, in the early '90s,
when he bought this domain — I want to say it was
registered in '92. Mind you, most people didn't
even know the internet existed until about '94,
'95. Regular home adoption didn't really happen
until '96, '97, but at that time, in '92, '94,
.net was actually the preferred — most people
thought .net, because most of the people using the
internet were network providers. These were ISPs,
it was a read-only or write-only. It was mostly
tech, not in the way that we think about it today,
but really hardware tech companies that
were utilizing the internet at that time,
other than just putting up a splash page like
a business card, and they were using .net. He
had a lot of very, very good .net domain names
at a time when he could have registered any of
them in .com. There's so many ways to segue this,
but he actually is the guy that — he originally
registered — you brought up x.com. There's three
one-letter .com domains in existence, okay? That's
it, three. It's Z, Q, and X, but Adam —
Tim Ferriss: Why are there only three?
Andrew Rosener: I'll tell you the story.
Adam actually registered all other 23,
okay? Numbers aren't allowed, single numbers
are just not allowed for security conflicts.
Prevented by ICANN from being registered. He
went and registered all the other one-letter
.com domain names, but because he wasn't using
them, ICANN then decided, "This is a bad idea,
nobody should be able to have these one letters,"
so they pulled back all but the three which they
grandfathered in, because Nissan was using z.com
for their 300Z car, which was quite popular at
the time. I think Quest Communications
was using Q, and Elon as it were, was
using X at the time. It was actually originally
owned by a lawyer and Elon bought it from him
prior to merging with Peter Thiel for PayPal.
Those three got grandfathered in and the rest
got pulled back. I have read quite a bit about
it. I think the way ICANN was thinking about
it was like maybe there was an element of
security, they're a socialist organization,
so they probably thought it was unfair for any
one company to dominate a letter of the alphabet,
but for a variety of reasons, they —
Tim Ferriss: Clawed them all
back except for three.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Pizza.net.
Andrew Rosener: Pizza.net, long story short,
I sold pizza.net, I think it was for like
$120,000 at the time, which used to be a lot
of money. I earned probably a $20,000 commission
on that, probably the owner made $100,000 net,
more or less, and that was a lot of money for me.
I had this mantra. At that time, I had just left
the job where I was making about three, 400 grand
a year consistently, and I was 26 years old, or 25
years old, whatever it was. I was making a lot of
money, way more than any of my peers. I literally
jumped ship, moved to Panama, started this
brokerage business, and I had a limited amount
of savings. I had spent most of it on domain names
and I had a limited amount of savings. And it was
basically just enough for us to last one year, I
had this mantra of every single day, five days a
week, every day, I need to make $250 profit. If I
don't make $250, then I am already falling behind
the eight-ball. But if I can make $250 every
day minimum, then my business will survive.
Tim Ferriss: How did you arrive at that number?
Andrew Rosener: I calculated what my annual
expenses were going to be in totality and
divided by the number of business days. And
it was really that simple, and this is another
thing, it came from Peter. It was like, look,
keep your expenses low. All my competitors, they
were doing sort of different things, but they
were all trying to be very technical about it and
build scalable businesses and lots of people and
lots of technology and huge overhead. And at that
time, I had basically no overhead. And so anyways,
I was turning along and doing whatever it took.
I would give away a domain name just to make
$250 that would say it didn't matter. Even if I
knew I was doing something that was going to be
harmful to me, literally, I was not going to end
my day until I made $250. And if I didn't make it,
which was very rare, the next day I had to make,
not double but triple. It was just punishment. It
was like, okay. So anyways, I really stuck
to that and I think that that was a very
powerful discipline for me in that first year.
Tim Ferriss: But in brief, because I know a lot of
folks listening are going to wonder, why Panama?
Andrew Rosener: So we originally planned to move
back to Europe and the sky was falling. And so
we thought we really hated being in the US where
it was really just being inundated with bad
news all the time. And we just thought, okay,
well, it's going to just be more of the same
in Europe. Germany would've been the obvious
next step. So we kind of said like, "Okay,
we really want to escape that environment,
particularly we're going to launch a new business.
I need some positivity. What I don't need is
constant negative vibes around me all the time."
The other thing was that this was — we left in
November, and so it was like a
bitter New England cold winter,
horrible cold. And I remember my wife got stuck.
She had a manual car. She was driving up a hill
in Providence, and she got stuck in the snow.
Tim Ferriss: I can imagine the German curses.
Andrew Rosener: And so anyways, it was
like, "Look, we're doing this business
that we can do from anywhere, and so let's
go somewhere warm." And I was like, "Yeah,
let's go somewhere warm." And so we kind
of explored all these different places.
We visited a lot of places in the Caribbean and
we'd gone to Central America, and I had been to
Panama actually a couple of years earlier because
of a friend of mine from college was Panamanian
and invited me down. And so Panama just checked a
lot of boxes. It was on the US dollar. Most of my
business was going to be in US dollars. So that
eliminated the currency friction of volatility.
Tim Ferriss: Didn't even think of that.
Andrew Rosener: That was big. That was a
big reason. It was very safe at that time. Panama
was the fastest growing economy in the world from
a GDP perspective. I think it was 13 point
a half percent GDP growth in 2008 or 2009,
whereas China was number two with 11
percent. Right. So huge GDP growth.
Tim Ferriss: Why was there so much GDP growth?
Andrew Rosener: Well, Panama —
Tim Ferriss: So banking sector, or no?
Andrew Rosener: Well, yeah. So the banking
sector was growing rapidly. The Panama Canal
was expanding, and as global — we were basically
really, let's say for that first decade of
the 2000s, that was kind of peak globalism.
It was like, "Wow, everybody's doing trade with
everybody." That got sort of short-stopped with
the financial crisis, but things were booming.
So anyways, Panama ticked all the boxes.
That was really why we landed on Panama.
Tim Ferriss: So you're in Panama, pizza.net. Holy
shit, this is going to cover a lot of $250 days.
Andrew Rosener: Totally.
Tim Ferriss: Right. This could be a business.
Andrew Rosener: It was super important that I was
hyper-focused on earning $250 a day, which you're
going to have a hard time really building a big
business if your focus is on making $250 a day.
But it was critical for that first year to have
that small goal and be achieving it regularly.
But then when I got my first bigger win,
it gave me the ability to take a deep breath
and then say, "Okay, I think this business is
going to work and I can start thinking bigger."
And I lost the discipline of the $250 a day,
but I started hunting bigger fish with the
inherent confidence that came with achieving
this discipline of hitting these small targets.
Tim Ferriss: So, hunting bigger fish.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: This then
brings us back to the question of valuations
and acceptable cost. So how do you think about
this? Or how should people think about it
is too broad. But how do you think about it?
Tim Ferriss [PSA to listeners]: Andrew and
I got into the weeds on domain valuation. We
really got into the technicalities, which is super
interesting. So be sure to stick around to hear
Andrew's answer related to how do you actually
determine an objectively defensible valuation
for domain names. Fascinating topic, but it got
quite detailed, so we moved it to the end of the
conversation. So stick around.
[Conversation resumes.]
Tim Ferriss: What I wanted to ask about is
something that people might find surprising,
and this is a note that I have in
front of me. I was surprised too.
It says: "Startups, in particular, should
not buy their domain name. They should
lease the best possible .com domain name
to their business with an optional path
to buy later." Can you elaborate on this?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. Yeah. So this is a big
decision/important decision/terrifying
risk for a lot of startups —
Tim Ferriss: Why do you say what you just said?
Andrew Rosener: — or they wait and then they get,
extorted is a strong word, but
done in. They really get bent
over the barrel because they purchase —
Andrew Rosener: Extorted is not actually
the worst-case scenario. The worst-case
scenario is that they no longer have a
path to ownership for their exact
brand match .com. That's actually
the worst-case scenario. That's a much worse
scenario than we have to pay some exorbitant
fee to get our domain name. Now explain why.
So about 2015, okay, 2014-2015, we started seeing,
really, like a parabolic rise in the value of
domain names. I don't even know really what to
attribute it to, but there was a sudden
sort of inflection point where more and
more investors, and when I say investors, I mean
really primarily VCs, as well as startup founders.
I think the startup founders part I understand.
That area, around 2012-2015, was sort of a lot
of the guys that had a win, or let's say might
have had a win, but then didn't sell fast enough
when the .com boom happened, but a lot of those
like early .com successes were coming back for
their second shot in that sort of time period.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's true. I mean I can for
sure confirm that, because I was in Silicon Valley
at the time and a lot of guys who had their first
win in 2007, '08, '09, or maybe that's when they
started a company and they had just taken some
secondary off the table, so maybe they had an
IPR, but they were flush with cash and they were
looking to build more things.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I saw this a lot, 100 percent.
Andrew Rosener: So I think, like anybody
who is successful, they learned from previous
experience, and a lot of them understood that,
okay, I launched on this silly name and I might
have gotten lucky and been successful because
the market wasn't crowded, but now the market
is crowded and now there's a million people
that want to compete with me and there's a lot
more resources to fund those people who want to
compete with me, so I need a strategic advantage
that my competitors can't — that gives me a moat.
And a domain name is one of those advantages.
So a lot of repeat founders, this is a trend
that I see, first-time founder pushes back a
lot on buying their exact brand match .com. They
see it as a risk, as you said. Most people
perceive it as a risk. What I would tell you
is it's actually a de-risking. A lot of —
Tim Ferriss: I want to make sure we talk
about leasing.
Andrew Rosener:
Yeah. This is why we're going
to circle back to this, okay?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Andrew Rosener: Now this
is actually directly leading into the leasing.
Tim Ferriss: Let me, just to straw man this a
little bit, if somebody is in a weak
cash position and then it could be
risky to overpay in the early stages —
Andrew Rosener: Sure. But this is where
it's going to dovetail into the leasing. Because I
think regardless of the cash position that you're
in — not regardless completely, but within
a realm, it's a better strategy — leasing
rather than an up-front, just all-out purchase.
So around that time, 2014-2015, domain names
really started to rise, and I was sort of telling
you what I attribute that to, but as the values
started going up it became harder and harder
to sell these things. There was less people
who could afford to buy them, and there was some
companies offering financing, but at very high
rates and not super attractive to most businesses.
So I was trying to come up with ways to increase
the pool of potential buyers and increase
my ability to close sales. So I thought
well, you know, we're all — I say we're all,
because I actually owned a lot of domain
names. We're sitting on these domain names
that we all know are really amazing assets,
they keep going up in value, but they're
so underutilized sitting in our portfolios.
Really the whole parking thing,
which used to be big business,
like we used to make real money from Google
with parking, but around 2008-2009, it's been
a downhill slope ever since. We used to get the
lion's share of revenue and now we get peanuts.
So as the values went up sales got harder,
and I came up with this idea of like well,
why don't I just lease you the domain? I'll give
you a fixed price option, so you have an exclusive
option to buy this domain. Nobody else can buy
it. Even if somebody shows up and says, "I'll
give $10 million for that domain that you leased
to this guy for a thousand dollars a month,"
nothing I can do about it.
We use escrow.com, is one of our biggest
partners, a third-party escrow service. I would
encourage anybody doing a domain transaction,
in my opinion the only — maybe if he is a lawyer,
but other than that the only safe way to conduct
a domain transaction. It used to be owned by
Fidelity. Then it was sold to a private guy,
and then that guy sold it to Freelancer, which is
a public company from Australia, freelancer.com,
who are the sole owner of the company now.
Anyways, we're going to put the domain in
escrow.com. That way, no matter what somebody
else offers me, no matter if I change my mind,
there's nothing I can do. Unless you, as the
person leasing the domain, breaches the contract
that we enter into there's nothing I can do.
You keep making your monthly payments right
off into the sunset, you might not even ever
have to talk to me again if you don't want to.
Tim Ferriss: Quick question. So with escrow.com,
who mediates a dispute where you say —
Andrew Rosener: It goes to arbitration.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. It goes into arbitration?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. Third-party arbitration.
Tim Ferriss: And they organize all of that,
or is that something you guys organize?
Andrew Rosener: I mean I am their number
one client. I've done hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars in sales and, knock on wood,
I've never one time ever had a
transaction go to arbitration.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I'm not saying — if it were —
Andrew Rosener: If it were, it goes through a
third-party forum, arbitration forum.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Okay. And they
will basically organize that?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. Because
they're the ones holding the domain. They've
got an interest in sorting this out as quickly
and amicably as possible. So they hold the
domain. There's usually a payment up front
which basically buys you an option, which like
in the world of finance like any other option.
You have an option to purchase this domain at
a fixed price for a fixed period of time. I
generally default to five years. I think
that's a great runway. Most businesses,
at a period of five years, are either going to
make it or break it. It's going to be binary.
At the five-year point either they know
they've got a business and their raising
either more funds, or their profitable, or
they achieve some level of scale, but they
either have a business or they don't. So at that
five-year point they have — and they can execute
at any time during the lease. They can execute
after the first monthly payment if they want to,
but within that five-year period they have a
fixed-price option to buy the domain exclusive
to them. And then they have a monthly lease.
So generally, rough back-of-the-napkin math,
the way these things usually fall is like
somewhere around five percent, it could be
10 percent, the bigger the value usually the
numbers come down, the lower the percentage.
Tim Ferriss: So it's over that
five-year period, you mean?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. So the purchase option —
and it's important that the startup have some
skin in the game —
Tim Ferriss: Oh,
I see. That's the initial option cost?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. The initial option —
Tim Ferriss: Not the total
cost during the five-year —
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. It's going to be the
initial option. Get some skin in the game,
buy yourself an option, and then you've got
a lease component. And the lease component
is going to usually be like a half a point.
Tim Ferriss: So does that option-up-front payment
act as an advance in the case that you purchase?
Andrew Rosener: In most cases, yes. Generally
speaking, we apply that option fee, so let's say
that you approach me, you want to buy a domain,
that domain is $100 thousand, we agree
to one of these lease deals. Maybe you're
going to put five or $10 thousand down up
front, and then you're going to have a 90
or $95 thousand fixed price option to buy.
Then you're going to have a lease component,
and the lease component is a true lease. Payments
don't go towards the purchase price, but it's half
a point. So like if it's a $100 thousand domain,
you might be paying $500, or maybe $1,000 a month.
It's a half a point or a point a month, which is
going to get the owner of the domain a reasonable,
conservative rate of return of five to 12 percent
rate of return, which is going to account for
inflation and account for the risk, and you're
going to have the opportunity for less than
the cost to keep your floor clean to operate
on your exact brand match .com from day one.
So that's the first element if de-risking, is
that, number one, you're never going to have to
rebrand, which is a very — because of SEO, because
of technical challenges, because of word-of-mouth
and a whole bunch of different things, a re-brand
while you're at stride is very difficult to pull
off and it leads to all sorts of messiness.
Generally speaking, it's going to cost you
somewhere between, depending on the
complexity of your organization,
between 10 and $40 thousand per employee to do a
domain name re-brand, to move from one domain to
another. Particularly it's higher and higher and
higher the later stage you are in the organization
and the more complexity you have.
So you are leasing the domain,
you're operating right from the get-go, you
look like you're a serious business right from
the get-go. You're not try this or get that.
Tim Ferriss: So a question to you on the sell
side, because now I'm super interested in
this. Now I'm thinking are there people who
just have a stable of domains and they treat it
almost like — and this isn't a perfect analogy,
but like a fixed income portfolio, and they're
like, "I'm not in the domain-selling business,
I'm actually in the domain-leasing business."
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: To run the math on that
model, if you were in that position,
you would want to know what percentage — just
so you can forecast properly, you'd want to
know roughly what percentage you would expect
to convert to buyers at the five-year point.
Andrew Rosener: Do you care, though? Really?
Tim Ferriss: I'm curious what it is.
Andrew Rosener: This is literally one of my
favorite topics. This was part of the whole
revelation of creating this, was I was sitting
back and I was saying to myself I've got about
5,000 really good domain names. Let's just take
the top 500. These would all be domain names that
like, at an absolute minimum, you're talking
about $100 thousand, and that would be cheap,
so $100 thousand and up. Some of these are eight
figures. Some of these are seven figures. Some of
these are mid-six figures, like $100 thousand
to many millions of dollars, okay, in value.
The price I would expect to sell them for, if I
just took the top 500 domain names and I — let's
just say I'm giving them away. I'm going to give
away all of them for 500 bucks a month. That's
$250 thousand a month in totally passive income.
And when I say passive income, like you would be
hard-pressed to find more passive income, because
it's not like a real estate portfolio, where once
in a while you've got a pissed-off tenant.
Tim Ferriss: There's a dead rat in the
HVAC — you've got to fucking deal with it.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. You've got to deal with
broken pipes and electricians. Then you've got
local and state real estate taxes. Then you've
got dah, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah. What you get
gross is very different than what you get net,
and not to mention the time investment.
So I laugh when I hear people in the real
estate business talking about passive income.
But it truly is passive income. It's literally
set it and forget it. I literally
hand the domain off to escrow.com,
the servers get pointed to the person leasing
it, and I get a notification once a month that
the payment was received, end of story. That's it.
So that's a pretty good gig. When I did that math
and I was like, "Wow, I like those numbers,"
it got me pretty excited and I started to
pursue this. I talked to GoDaddy and I talked to
some other players in the industry, saying, "Why
don't we promote this as the way that companies
should sell domain names or acquire a domain?"
From there the concept evolved in my head to
the point where it's really a no-brainer. So
even if you have the money, like, why lay out
the cash if you can lease it? Even if you know
you want to buy it and you have the money to buy
it, you probably have a better use case for the
cash flow. It's literally going to cost you in
most cases less than you pay to keep your floor
clean in your office to have this domain name.
Like the lowest-paid person in your company costs
more than your company's branded domain
name per month, so it's a no-brainer,
in my opinion, for almost everybody.
When you go to raise funds and you go to
your VC, I am, I don't know — IAmVida.com.
I'm an investor in a company called Vida,
which is a good segue into another element
of this that you sort of referenced.
But, anyways, it's a lot easier
to raise capital going and saying,
"We are Vida and we have vida.com," rather
than, "We're Try Vida," or "We're vida.io,"
or "We're vida.xyz." You're not a serious
company. It's like you're on training wheels.
So at some point, and most of the smart VCs
know this, at some point you're going to have
to upgrade, because there's a ceiling — you'd be
hard-pressed — there are a few exceptions, but I
think you'd be hard-pressed to tell me a company
valued over $1 billion that isn't on a .com. You'd
be pretty hard-pressed. I think there's only
one Fortune 1000 company that is not on a .com.
So at some point, for a variety of reasons,
you're going to hit a ceiling if you do
not have your exact brand match .com.
Maybe it's because you want to go public
and your investment bank, which was the case
with Facebook — when they wanted to go public,
the investment bank, whoever it was, the
auditors, whoever it was, came in and said,
"You guys need to own all your IP before we're
going to take you public." So last minute
they had to go out and buy fb.com from American
Farm Bureau, and they paid $8.5 million for it,
because literally a banker told them they
can't go public until they wrap up this ID.
Or maybe you're going to raise your next
round of funding and your VC says, "Look,
if you don't have your .com at this stage, it's
this huge risk. We're looking for 100X here. We
want you to be a $10 billion company or $100
billion company, and you can't do that without
your .com. So if you don't get it at this stage,
then we don't know what it's going to cost later,
or you might not be able to get it later," and
they realize that that's just an inherent risk.
So there's a bunch of advantages. Let's say
lubricating the fundraising process, de-risking
that process in the mind of the investors, as well
as the downsize risk of not doing so and looking
like you're not serious, or you have a short-term
vision, or you're not committed to your brand.
Tim Ferriss: Vida — you mentioned you were an
investor, and you said that relates to another
element of this. What is that other element?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. So I mentioned that just
because — so Stephanie Tilenius, who was a
very early employee at Yahoo and PayPal, I
think in 2012, Woman of the Year in Technology,
phenomenal founder, she approached me to buy
vida.com. She didn't want to pay —
Tim Ferriss: V-I-T-A?
Andrew Rosener: V-I-D-A.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. V-I-D-A?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. The Spanish word for life.
Tim Ferriss: Yep. Got it.
Andrew Rosener: She was building this health
tech business and she wanted to buy vida.com,
and she understood — I mean she had
worked for and had worked with a lot
of Silicon Valley's most famous founders,
and she was committed to owning vida.com,
and she didn't want to pay the
price. I won't get into the numbers,
but she didn't want to pay my price. I loved
that. That was one of my favorite domain names.
Tim Ferriss: You say that to all the
girls, "This one is my favorite."
Andrew Rosener: So we were working through
ideas on how could this work, and if anything,
I'm extremely open-minded. So I was just throwing
spaghetti into the wall to see what would stick,
and I was like, "Look, give me a piece of
equity in lieu of cash." She was saying,
"Oh, that's an idea." So she went back to
her board and came back and we did a deal.
There was some cash, I think there was milestone
cash payments, and there was a small piece of
equity valued at precisely the delta. There was
no funny business. I didn't increase the price.
It was just we're going to make up for that
delta between what we're going to pay in cash
and what you wanted in cash with equity.
Tim Ferriss: When you say milestone-based
cash payments, what type of milestones? Or
hypothetically? Was it like "We raise this
round and we give you a little more, then we
raise this round and give you a little more?"
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. Or
even just as simple as time.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Your payment schedule?
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. And that deal,
like the leasing idea, triggered in my mind that
I can actually act like a venture capitalist.
But instead of putting capital money into
these companies, I can treat these domain
names as capital, and interestingly I get the best
position on the cap table because in my contracts,
if you fail, I just claw the domain back,
because your equity goes to zero. So that was —
Tim Ferriss: That's an important clause.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. So it doesn't always work,
right? I mean it depends on who the company is,
who its founders are. It's a negotiation like
anything else. But generally speaking we've got a
clawback clause. Otherwise we need to mark up the
domain to account for the risk. But we started
doing that, and so now, I don't know, we got
quite a number of startups that we have a piece
of equity in, that we've literally invested in,
but we didn't invest cash. We invested a domain
name. In some of them I invested cash on top
because I was excited about the opportunity, but —
Tim Ferriss: I thought about doing this with the
podcast occasionally, just because in
a sense I do enjoy the startup game at
times. I don't want to do it full-time. I
don't want at this point to have a fund or
anything like that. I just don't want LPs to
deal with, any of that babysitting, frankly.
But if I have, as you do for instance, a
competitive advantage in spotting things,
that could become very interesting. So
when someone comes in and you learn about
a company that perhaps hasn't launched, or
hasn't made that quantum leap but they're on
the cusp of having bankroll to potentially buy
something, where you have a conversation and you
realize they're very strategically minded,
analytical, like this founder you mentioned,
especially with that clawback, that's interesting.
Andrew Rosener: That's super interesting.
Tim Ferriss: That diversified business model.
Andrew Rosener: And quite literally
it just interests me. It's a lot more interesting
than a domain sale. It's like, oh, I get to come
along for the ride. So this comes back to another
thing, which is I actually fundamentally believe
that we are still in the early stages of
domain names and domain value, the early
stages of digital commerce and the internet.
Most people in the world have been online for
less than 25 years. That's a pretty short period
of time. As we see commercial real estate sort of
dying and all the distress in commercial real
estate, we're seeing digital real estate boom,
okay? And there's a direct correlation
there. I want to say a causation.
So, again, what is a domain name? It's the place
where you meet your customer. It's the only place
that you own that you meet your customer. Where
it used to be the retail store, or the office,
or the, you know, whatever, something brick and
mortar, now it's digital, and that digital place
where you meet your customer is a domain name.
Now some people have argued and they've — for
many years I've heard everything. Originally
it was like — I remember when Absolut vodka
launched the first billboard campaign, where
they didn't advertise their own domain name. They
advertised their Facebook page. And I remember
seeing that billboard and thinking to myself,
"How stupid." Like you are literally at
least, I don't know, 20 — I'm pulling a
number out of my head, but it's got to be 20
or 30 percent of the equity that you're buying
with that billboard is going to Facebook.
And then when the customer goes to Facebook,
you don't even own that relationship. You don't
own the data. You don't own the relationship. You
could be shut off at will. Like there's nothing
you could do about it, right? And that was before
cancel culture. Now it's like a serious problem.
Tim Ferriss: I chatted with this guy ages ago.
He was also a snake eater in the shadows,
not in a bad way, but he was very discreet,
he was very ethical, but he had these Facebook
pages. He would buy Facebook pages. They were
doing well, and then 10X, 20X, these pages. They
weren't exactly roll-ups, but he would accumulate
these things, and he had these portfolios,
and one of them was just minting money.
I can't remember what it was. It was just
millions and millions of dollars a month,
and I asked him what it was like having
and running that page, and he said,
"It's like having the most profitable McDonald's
in the world on top of an active volcano, because
I just cannot predict what is going to happen."
Andrew Rosener: You know it's going to erupt,
you just don't know when.
Tim Ferriss: All right,
I want to segue here for a
second. Speaking of branding,
Fuckyourself.com, why did you buy this?
Andrew Rosener: This is remarkably
timely. Well, so as I alluded to earlier in this
conversation, I get literally thousands of emails
a day. Okay. So I am — I don't know, maybe there's
somebody out there that gets more, but I'm kind of
like one of the world's power users of email.
I get roughly 2,500 to 3,000 emails a day.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Andrew Rosener: I don't
use a spam filter. And because really
in my business, it's all about the —
Tim Ferriss: I can imagine a lot of
the legitimate emails are kind of
indistinguishable from what would get flagged.
Andrew Rosener: And so I gave up on spam filters
years ago, and I just bite the bullet and I've
tried a million different things and always,
there's just some degree of loss I'm not willing
to accept. And so I just literally muscle through
it every single day and it's really the only
thing in my life that I'm captive to. I've
really optimized my life for freedom except
email, email's still my ball and chain. So
at some point, very early — it gets tiring.
You get a lot of crazy people and a lot of
just garbage. And so somebody presented me
with Fuckyourself.com and I thought, wow,
I want to buy that domain just to have the email
address go at Fuckyourself.com and then I'm going
to create an autoresponder. And so all of these
idiots emailing me, I'm going to literally just
email them back from Go@fuckyourself.com. And
I cannot tell you how much pleasure that has
brought me. I don't know what that says about
me, but literally, it truly was one of the
best purchases I've ever made in my life.
Tim Ferriss: Just so I'm clear, everyone
who emails you gets an auto-response?
Andrew Rosener: No, no, no, no, no, no,
no. It was selective. It was selective. There
were certain emails that I then set up to be
auto-responded to, like consistent emails that
I would get. They would be put into the file,
they'd be auto-responded directly
from Go@fuckyourself.com, and then
other people I would just use more surgically
when appropriate and sometimes inappropriate.
But the problem — I was having fun with it, and
I still get a lot of pleasure from it. But the
problem was that it turns out that everybody
on Earth, in nearly every country, from what I
can tell, when they fill out a form and they
don't want to give their email address, the
email address they give is Go@fuckyourself.com.
And so Go@fuckyourself.com literally gets over
100,000 emails a day.
Tim Ferriss: What?
Andrew Rosener: Yes. So it is completely
unusable as a vanity email address,
but it is still fun as a responder.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's funny. That's
funny. You know what that makes me think of? I
don't know why this just popped into my head. I
think it's kind of funny. Maybe I've seen The Big
Lebowski too many times, but I went to this bar —
Andrew Rosener: No such thing as too many times —
Tim Ferriss: At Hôtel Biron, I think it was,
in San Francisco at some point, and this
was pretty early, this was a long time ago,
with a lot of the digital signatures at
a kiosk of some type when you check out,
and I had had quite a bit to drink, and it
came time to sign. And I asked the guy who
was standing there, like, how many people just
draw dicks when they sign? And he was like,
"About 80 percent of the guys."
Andrew Rosener: Come on.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah!
Andrew Rosener: I don't know why that's
never occurred to me, but that's literally
going to be the way I sign from now on.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Andrew Rosener: Yes, it's exactly
the same vein, pun intended.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, God.
Andrew Rosener: So brutal.
Tim Ferriss: All right. This brings up,
if I may segue from Fuckyourself.com, this
leads very cleanly to anger management.
So talk to me about anger management.
Andrew Rosener: Well, I attribute my,
let's say, evolution of my anger management to
you. I guess it's part of the reason I bought
Fuckyourself.com, it's part of the reason that
I have the reputation I do, which is quite — I
don't want to say belligerent, but I —
Tim Ferriss: Aggressive? Aggressive?
Andrew Rosener: I don't suffer fools gladly.
And I'm not afraid to speak my mind at all
times. I am the self-designated counterweight
to political correctness. And so I just like to
keep it real. But anyways, a part of that
is anger. I have a deep — I don't know,
I have a deep emotional anger. It's a fire that
burns in me, and it's not always there. But
when I get triggered, which is fairly often,
it shows its ugly head. And so I would say
that in my earlier life, it actually served me
well. I would've even called it a superpower.
But as I've gotten older and as I've evolved in
business and as I've evolved in my marriage and
as I've evolved in relationships, it's not
necessarily my friend. And so I've had to
deal with that. But it was listening to a podcast
that you did many years ago talking about yourself
dealing with anger issues and anger management.
It sort of was the first time I even went, "Oh,
maybe I've got an issue. Maybe this isn't normal."
And so it was that recognition that led me to seek
out ways to start dealing with it. And it's
an ongoing process, but I think it's a good
highlight of things that previously served me
that no longer do. And then figuring out how
to — it even became a part of my identity,
both self-inflicted as well as others.
Tim Ferriss: For sure.
Andrew Rosener: It becomes a part of like —
Tim Ferriss: And when it is your default, you also
find ways to justify it or paint it sometimes in
the best light possible.
Andrew Rosener: Totally.
Tim Ferriss: It's like buying that domain.
Tim Ferriss: And all of a sudden you're
like, "This is my superpower. Let me create
a narrative around that."
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And it may be true in part, but
then you create blind spots for yourself.
Andrew Rosener: Absolutely. But it's precisely
what you said. You create a narrative around
it that suits you to justify it, which further
ingrains it into who you are or who you believe
you are. And at some point it stops serving you.
And it doesn't have to be anger. It can be many
things, many emotions, or maybe many just
self-identifying characteristics. And it's
very difficult to then change your software and
say like, "Oh, I don't need that anymore." And
I'm still working on how to do it, but I've made
a lot of progress, you need an outlet for it,
so I started boxing. You need to reflect on it
constantly to understand what are the triggers
and understand, "Okay, when I get one of
these triggers, I need to just walk away,
stay silent, whatever it might be." But
trying to find ways to not engage with it.
And then always reminding yourself that this is
not something, this isn't who I am anymore or
this isn't something I need anymore. This isn't
a tool that I need anymore, is really the way
that I look at it. I wanted to attribute that
to you because you've done God's work in a lot
of your podcasts and talking about this issue
and how you've dealt with it. And that has sent
me down a lot of rabbit holes. I am very good
at picking up on these threads and then diving
down the rabbit hole and exploring. So.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I appreciate you
saying that, man. And I want to also show the
cover and title of a book that you brought.
So I want to also thank you for this beauty. So
this is How to Keep Your Cool: An Ancient Guide
to Anger Management. And this is by one of my
favorites, of course, Seneca the Younger, a very
controversial figure for a lot of good
reasons. And this is, I want to say, On Anger.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: De Ira. And
I've tried to digest the original, well, not the
original, I should say the translated original.
Andrew Rosener: This has both.
Tim Ferriss: This has both. And
it's very well done. And when you gave this
to me, I said, "You know what? I could really
use this because I want to revisit it." And I
listened to it on audiobook last summer actually,
and found it incredibly helpful. And it's in
some ways similar to an audiobook I listened to,
which was, I think it's The Easy Way to Quit
Caffeine, which is based on a method used for
helping people to quit smoking. I think it's
called The Easy Way for Quitting Smoking. And
it's a little hokey, Dale Carnegie-ish. But the
fact of the matter is, I stopped with a few other
elements and did 30 days with zero caffeine
for the first time since I was probably 18.
Andrew Rosener: That is so unimaginable for me.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I know, I know. But it was
unimaginable for me as well.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But it effectively takes you through
all of the reasons and justifications that you
use for consuming caffeine and just dismantles
them one by one. And I feel like this, How to
Keep Your Cool, does something very similar.
Andrew Rosener: It makes me feel foolish. It
makes me, when I lose my temper, it makes
me say, "You idiot, what are you doing? You
can't even control your temper. What are you
doing?" I just keep it on my desk. Really,
I reference it. But more than anything, I keep
it on my desk and it's a reminder that when some
troll on the internet pisses me off or somebody
I'm on the phone with, somebody gets me off.
Tim Ferriss: Someone's outraged because they
got an auto response from Go@fuckyourself.com.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah! How dare you!
Tim Ferriss: How dare they!
Andrew Rosener: It reminds me,
it's there. It's in my purview
and it reminds me, like, keep it cool.
Tim Ferriss: So you have this on your
desk as a reminder.
Andrew Rosener: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: I like that.
Tim Ferriss: Maybe that's how I'll use it. It's
hard to miss. It's got like a giant stop sign —
Andrew Rosener: Totally. And it's orange.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It's a giant stop sign.
Andrew Rosener: Totally.
Tim Ferriss: All right,
so you mentioned, I want to know if you have
any suggestions. You mentioned you might be
the world's number one email power user. A lot of
people feel beholden to email. Any recommendations
for folks? Or are you just like, "Hey man,
I need to go to the email methadone clinic
too? I don't have any recommendations for that."
Andrew Rosener: Yeah, no, no. I am 100 percent the
wrong person. So I have completely capitulated
and I really — I just muscle through it every
single day. I basically have accepted that
I have about a two and a half hour window
every single day where it's just clean the
inbox. So first two and a half hours of my day
almost every day are highly caffeinated muscling
through my inbox. And then my real day starts.
Tim Ferriss: Do you just go through
G Suite or Gmail or do you use
other tools at all, or you just —
Andrew Rosener: I use Apple Mail,
but our domain is on Google.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Andrew Rosener: But I don't use any filters. I
occasionally, let's say every couple months I'll
go in and I'll do the unsubscribe thing, but
I honestly find that the more you unsubscribe,
the more you get subscribed to other things, I
think that that's the hook. But for the first
time in my life, I'm optimistic. I think that it
seems like low-hanging fruit. And if there's an
AI company super specialized in email filtering,
please reach out to me. I would very much welcome
your assistance. But I think that AI is going to
be a really powerful tool. I think that what I do
is replicable by AI. I tried it with an assistant
twice. I've had an assistant who would at least
eliminate the low-hanging fruit. But teaching them
the way I think about it, helping them understand,
like, "Don't delete that, that is actually
a really good domain name for XYZ reason."
And it's only this crazy library of esoteric
knowledge that I've accumulated that allows
me to see that diamond in the rough.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, if you're getting
through 1,500 or 2,000 emails in two and a
half hours, I think most people are going
to be astonished at the speed.
Andrew Rosener: I'm really good.
Tim Ferriss: So you must archive, I
mean, a very high percentage of this.
Andrew Rosener: Yep, yep, a lot. It's literally,
I think if there was a single place where I would
be like, you and I differ more, I think this
would be the one. It's — pure chaos. It's pure
chaos. Anybody that works for me is like, "What
do you mean you just operate from your inbox? Your
inbox is just a tool." "No, no, no, this is my
dashboard. This is like everything is in my inbox,
everything." So yeah, so I don't have any tips
or tricks. I really welcome the use of AI to,
I think finally be able to
replicate what it is I do. It
is repetitive. So I think I can use AI to do that.
Tim Ferriss: All right. I have a related question.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah, go.
Tim Ferriss: So I have related question,
which I've been sitting on. I took a note so I
wouldn't forget that is related to AI. So more
and more people are using ChatGPT or Bard for
various purposes, putting together itineraries,
and they're using them in place of, say, Google.
The results are very different. And one of the
narratives out there, which I think it probably
has some degree of substance to it, is that
it appears that Google got kind of caught with
its pants down a little bit with ChatGPT, even
though I have a very high degree of confidence
that they'll make very, very fast progress.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But nonetheless,
it was because there was a question of how to
use this technology. It's also a much larger
company and just has sort of machinations and
processes that a tiny startup does not. However,
what I was going to say is Google has the greatest
moneymaker in the history of the internet. So how
do you capitalize on AI without killing the golden
goose is an important question. I would imagine —
Andrew Rosener: A trillion dollar question —
Tim Ferriss: — as a layperson, that these
tools are going to affect the domain world in
some capacity. How do you think about that?
Andrew Rosener: When social media came on
the scene, everybody pushed back and said,
"Well, my domain is less important
now. I connect with people on social
media." Okay, you're going to regret that.
Then apps came on the scene and it was like, "Oh,
your domain isn't that important for me. People
don't even go to the web anymore. They just use
apps." And then everybody has 2,000 apps on their
phone and it's like, eh, I'm not sure that's much
better. And now there's lots of security issues
with apps, and now Google is basically trying
to kill apps. And so every iteration of this,
of the way humans interact with the internet,
offers up the fresh new death of domain
names. Okay. But basically domain names are
the foundational layer, they're the bedrock
layer of the digital world. Everything else
is built on top of that. So domain names are
some super geeky technologist, hard tech guy
is going to tell me — but for the most part, for
the consumer, internet domain names are layer one.
Tim Ferriss: Instead of your auto response.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. I know there's all these
protocols that are underneath that are really
the layer one of the internet. I understand
that. But for the consumer internet, the part
that matters to e-commerce and the consumer,
domain names are layer one. They're the bedrock
foundation of doing commerce on the internet.
If we were to stop launching new companies today
or putting out new ideas on the internet because,
"Oh, you can just use ChatGPT or Bard for that,
right?" First off, I would love to see the data,
but I bet you same as 80 percent of the people
sign the digital signature thing with a dick,
99 percent of the people using ChatGPT
are using it for some stupid thing like
"What's the best way to peel a banana?" Right?
But these things aren't creating new ideas. They
are really good at finding solutions from
existing ideas and putting those things
together in creative ways and lots of different
useful stuff. But if we were to just get lazy
as human species and say, "Oh, AI's here, we're
done. We don't need to create new companies. We
don't need to put out new Wikipedias or new
information or new art." We literally just
stagnate because these things aren't creating
that next frontier. They're literally only
creating or remixing a stagnant lexicon of art.
Tim Ferriss: I guess I'm just wondering how those
tools, for instance — and the reason this is top
of mind for me is I ran into someone in their
20s who basically uses Bard in place of Google
now, primarily because the point she made was,
"I don't want to click through all these
different links and then click back and
have to compare these various things. It'll
basically summarize, put things into tables,
et cetera, for me in a whole bunch of different
instances." And so I thought to myself, well,
that's fascinating. I wonder
how that will affect the SEO
game and in part affect all these things.
Andrew Rosener: I think it'll tremendously
affect the SEO game. And I think it
will tremendously, or may tremendously,
affect the formula for how to value a domain,
but I don't think that it's going to tremendously
impact the fact that we continue to need them.
In fact, I think there's an argument to be made
that they become even more important because
suddenly it becomes, like — semantically, your
domain name needs to be semantically meaningful,
it needs to be easy to spell. You can't use these
cute spellings where you're missing a vowel or
you're on a .ly because people are going to say,
"Take me to Amazon," right, or, "Buy this
thing." If you're using an agent, it's like,
"Order me whatever it is," but you need to tell it
where to order that thing. And so it becomes even
more important to have a really semantically
meaningful domain name. That's my belief.
As for Google. It's an excellent question.
There's no way it doesn't cut into that ad
business. There's no way. Ultimately you're
going to see some cannibalization of the search
business. I think that's unavoidable.
Tim Ferriss: It seems to me that unique
products will be in a good position. If you are
a marketplace selling commoditized products, it's
going to be very challenging because I could use
an agent, just say, "Hey, buy this thing at the
best price that will get delivered to me in the
next two days. Use my Amex on file." Boom, done.
The other winner, I think that might emerge —
Andrew Rosener: Again, that addresses the
SEO and the competition game. But
wherever it's buying that thing from,
they still need the domain name.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, sure.
Andrew Rosener: Right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally,
totally agree. And I think another potential
winner, just like you said, I mean the demise,
the end is nigh for .coms, I've heard that
since I moved to Silicon Valley in 2000.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Same thing for email, right?
Andrew Rosener: Totally.
Tim Ferriss: "Email is dead,"
and I'm like, email is not dead.
Andrew Rosener: If anything,
is more valuable than ever —
Tim Ferriss: It's more valuable than
ever. And I think that is going to continue
to be the case as the web becomes a mess of
AI-enhanced misinformation, disinformation,
and just content spamming. I think that —
Andrew Rosener: Domain names are, in my opinion
— okay, now, there is a lot of unknowns with AI,
and I'm not smart enough to think all of
that through, all right. There may be a
threat on the horizon that I don't see for
sure, and I accept that. But in my opinion,
there is more reason to believe that domain names
are about to pop off in a major way because of a
couple of things. One is identity and how
important it's going to be, to be able to
verify real identity. And I think that domain
names, and I think that like Jack Dorsey is
on this. Jack Dorsey understands this, and he's
building around this; domain names are central to
everything that he's doing. So your domain name
is ultimately, shouldn't it make sense that in
order to get your Twitter handle, your X handle,
you should have the corresponding domain name? If
you're, I don't know, NBC, you should have —
Tim Ferriss: Got it. So this would be —
Andrew Rosener: X/NBC. x.com/nbc.
Tim Ferriss: This would be a sort
of very elegant, like KYC kind of thing.
Andrew Rosener: 100 percent. 100 percent. So it's
literally, KYC is the right way to describe it.
Tim Ferriss: Sorry, guys. "Know your
customer" stuff for people who, yeah.
Andrew Rosener: Exactly. So across the board,
from every aspect that you can think of from
financial to social media to e-commerce,
people interacting with the internet should
be identified by a domain name because it is
a really powerful way to identify somebody.
Tim Ferriss: So here's the question. Do you
think that's going to be —
Andrew Rosener: It ties the
physical to the digital world, it's that bridge.
Tim Ferriss: What do you think the extension will
be, or what form do you think that'll take?
Andrew Rosener: What do you mean?
Tim Ferriss: Well, do you think it'll be — I mean,
a lot of people have .eth, a lot of people have,
then you of course have .coms, but those
could be pricey. If I were to — do you have
any guess for what format that will take?
Andrew Rosener: I'm not going to tell you
a timeline, but I think that in some future, most
people in the first world that are engaging with
the internet on a regular basis are going
to have at least two, and in some cases,
three domains. Okay. They're going to
have their real identity domain name,
and that's going to be less important.
Basically, the more public facing you are,
the more pressure there will be to have
the .com, okay. But outside of that,
any extension will do. And then there's going
to be your pseudonymous identity, in which case
you really don't care what the extension is. And
then there's going to be your commercial identity,
whether that's the business you own, the
blog you run, but you're going to have at
least two. And if you have, let's say you've
planted a flag on the internet in one form or
another through a blog, a business, whatever
it might be, that's your third domain name.
I think most people are going to have two or three
domain names. Already today, you can use a .com
domain name and you can use it as a crypto
wallet. You can use the DNS records, without
going too deep into the weeds, you can use the DNS
records to basically insert your crypto address,
your Bitcoin address, or your Ethereum address
into the DNS records of your domain name. And
then people can send — like, I've got Drew.com.
I can use that as my Bitcoin wallet. And I think
that — so first feature of why I believe there's
this huge growth curve coming for domain names.
First is identity KYC. Okay? Second is finance
and wallets, specifically wallets, because again,
it's the same problem. It's like, "Yes,
you can use some of these Web3 domains,
these .eth," and I was one of the first investors
into unstoppable domains. I was literally probably
in the first 50 people ever in 2015 to register
a thousand .eth domains before anybody even knew
what these things were. I was a huge early
adopter of Handshake, and there's going to be
a lot of people that get upset with me. So I'm
going to try not to poo poo too much, but I do
spend a tremendous amount of time thinking about
these things, and I am very deep in it, obviously.
And so I have failed to identify a durable use
case for Web3 domain names. I think they're cute.
I think they have some utility, certainly in its
simplest form, they make good wallets. I don't
see a durable utility beyond that. It's definitely
better to have tim.eth or tim.whatever like Web3
domain name and have that instead of your Ethereum
address, which would be some very long hexadecimal
string impossible for most humans to remember.
Tim Ferriss: Also, very possible to fuck up.
Andrew Rosener: Exactly. That's not the thing you
want to mess up, right? It's one thing to go to
the wrong website. It's an entirely other thing
to be sending money to the wrong wallet. But that
actually makes the point. That's one of the big
Achilles heels of Web3 domains is that there's no
standard. I mentioned before, the ICANN governs
the, let's say the legacy DNS, the root zone.
If you have, I don't know, an unstoppable domain,
you've got timferriss.x, okay, they have the .x,
they've got .wallet, they've got whatever. So
let's say you've got tim.wallet. Okay, easy,
tim.wallet. And you tell me, "Hey, send me one
ETH." I can send you one ETH to tim.wallet because
today there's only one .wallet, but there's
absolutely nothing stopping me from starting
a new business tomorrow that also has .wallet or
from the Ethereum name service from launching a
.wallet. Or there is somebody on Handshake that
already has .wallet, and there's going to be,
every single blockchain is within that. You're
going to see that already in this cycle. But over
the next five years, every blockchain that exists
is going to have their own domain name service
because it's a very easy money grab. And —
Tim Ferriss: So you're saying there could
be bad actors doing bad things with
that amount of confusion?
Andrew Rosener: Totally. But
even if they're not bad actors, there's just
going to be a tremendous amount of confusion.
Tim Ferriss: Confusion, confusion. Yeah.
Andrew Rosener: Because you say, "Hey,
send me an ETH to the tim.wallet," but
depending on which wallet I'm using,
which wallet software I'm using, I don't know if
that's going to the Ethereum blockchain. Is that
going to the Handshake blockchain? Is that going
to the Unstoppable? Which blockchain is that on?
And so I could send it to Tim.wallet and it could
go to a different Tim.wallet, and I have, there's
nothing I can do about that unless I've got some
degree of tech-savvy and I can pull down a menu
and select which network I want to send this over.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's asking a lot of people.
Andrew Rosener: Way too much. That's never
going to happen. And so for that reason,
it's never going to resolve. The second thing is
that with decentralization, I think decentralized
money is great. I think decentralized information
is dangerous. And it comes down to one very simple
thing that I find most people can understand.
If you go to the average person and you say,
"Look, there's this one internet over here and
it's centralized to a certain degree and people
can shut you down and dah, dah, dah, but it's
kind of good enough. It's the internet you know
and love. But we got this fancy new internet
over here where it's totally decentralized…"
And believe me, I'm a libertarian. I'm kind of
a decentralization maximalist, but I've drawn a
line in the sand here for the following reason.
Tim Ferriss: And I'll just say, so the peanut
gallery doesn't go berserk. You are also, we
don't have time to get into this right now,
but a huge Bitcoin advocate.
Andrew Rosener: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Right. Just so people
know, yes, you're in the game.
Andrew Rosener: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: So please continue.
Andrew Rosener: In the game for a long time and
have a pretty deep understanding. So if presented
with two choices of this, here's the internet you
know and love. Here's this totally decentralized
new internet that has all these fancy bells and
whistles that you should love, except that there's
this one flaw and that flaw is somebody can put
child porn and there's nobody that can ever take
it down. And on that singular point is when I
made up my mind that that will never happen. The
Department of Justice, Department of Defense,
which owns the Department of Commerce, which
controls the internet, a lot of people don't know
that, is never, ever, ever, ever going to allow —
Tim Ferriss: That's wild. I had no idea.
Andrew Rosener: — any browser to resolve
these things. So you've got some fringe browsers
that do resolve them, but I think it's something
like 98 percent of all the internet traffic passes
through four browsers, right? It's like Firefox,
Safari, Chrome, and what was the —
Tim Ferriss: Explorer?
Andrew Rosener: Explorer, which is probably
a very small market share these days.
But that's basically all the traffic. And I can
promise you, I would put virtually everything I
have on the fact that those browsers are never
going to resolve a Web3 domain name ever.
Primarily for those reasons and other surrounding
reasons like that, the inability to ever censor
content, as well as the fact that they then
lose control to sniff every packet of data
that passes through the internet. And so that's
never going to happen. It's not going to happen.
There may be some parallel, like we've got
dark web now, but this is never going to be
a mainstream thing ever. But I do think they
make great wallet addresses to some extent
today. I think that it could get messy.
So you have to be careful. But it's funny,
the Ethereum name service guys actually are the
ones that figured out how to do this. So they kind
of shot themselves in the foot. But you can now
take a .com domain name or a .xyz domain name or
a .net domain name, and you can use the DNS, the
legacy DNS settings, and you can literally make
your domain name a wallet. And so that, to me is,
it's like that's obvious where we're going to go.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so we have five
minutes left. All right, so I want to before,
just in case I get excited and lose track,
where can people find Media Options?
Andrew Rosener: Mediaoptions.com. We have, if you
want to learn more about domain names, we have a —
Tim Ferriss: It's not mo.co? No, I'm kidding.
Andrew Rosener: No, no. I actually,
recently I just sold mo.co for exactly the
same reason I explained. I bought it when
.co kind of launched into the public sphere.
It was always the extension for Columbia,
but then it got sort of repurposed like —
Tim Ferriss: No, I was kidding. All right,
so just, before we side alley.
Andrew Rosener: Mediaoptions.com.
Tim Ferriss: Mediaoptions.com.
Andrew Rosener: And we've got domainsherpa.com,
which is our podcast that's about domain
names. So I don't suggest it unless you
want to learn about domain names and hear us —
Tim Ferriss: And are you active on Twitter?
Andrew Rosener: I'm very active on Twitter.
Twitter's the only social media I'm active on.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Andrew Rosener @AndrewRosener.
We'll link to all these things in the show notes.
Last question. The pursuit of happiness. So how
do you think about the pursuit of happiness?
Because I will say having spent time with you, you
strike me as overall, a pretty happy guy. Yo'veu
got a little methy edge to you, A little twitchy,
a little bouncy, but you smile a lot of the time.
Andrew Rosener: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: I don't know if you're
crying on the inside, but you seem like
generally a pretty happy-go-lucky guy.
Andrew Rosener: I'm a pretty content person.
Tim Ferriss: Content.
Andrew Rosener: Content. I have
moments of happiness, but I'm pretty
content, I think is the right —
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So tell
me more about this and what you —
Andrew Rosener: So I guess the way that
I think about it is that I generally
want to be content. I don't necessarily
pursue happiness, I pursue contentment.
Tim Ferriss: Is that wanting what you
have or being grateful? What does that mean?
Andrew Rosener: Yes. I think that's another
way of saying it, but for me personally, it's a
bit more that Terence McKenna had this theory of
novelty that ultimately, that's what evolution
is all about. It's just about the pursuit of
novelty. And that resonated with me. And I
basically surmised that I think the purpose
for each of our individual lives is truly, if
you zoom out and you look at it from a species
focus as opposed to an individual focus, the
purpose for each individual life is actually
just novelty. It's about unique characteristics
that make you you and how you engage with the
world around you and what that leads to. And this
novelty is actually the objective or should be the
objective, again, in my opinion. And so —
Tim Ferriss: Meaning there's a variety of
different characteristics, survival of
the fittest, is that how the novelty —
Andrew Rosener: Sure. Not necessarily. I think
survival of the fittest is a mechanic in the
game, but it's not necessarily —
Tim Ferriss: The end all be all.
Andrew Rosener: The end all be all of the game.
I think it's really just about the pursuit of
novelty, that you need to do things that nobody's
done before. You need to react to things in a
way that is not typical. If you do things like
everybody else has done things or everybody else
does things, then you can't expect a different
outcome than what everybody else has had. And
I certainly am not looking for the outcome that
everybody else has. It's just not, I got one shot
at this thing, I want to do something else. I want
to stand out. I want to pursue greatness, whatever
that means. But I certainly, above all else, I
don't want to be like other people. I don't want
to be like anybody else, like any other individual
or any other group of individuals. I don't
like labels. I just want to pursue novelty.
And what I found that to mean, once you go another
layer, is that really what most of life is, is
actually friction and pain and suffering. And we
have developed our society to run away from that.
We're always, "You have a right to happiness,
you should be in the pursuit of happiness." And
I think that makes us soft. I think that makes
us avoid risk. I think that makes us avoid pain.
It makes us avoid hard work. And everything that
I've seen, everything that I enjoy, comes at the
expense of pain, suffering, hard work, whether
that's my marriage, it's a lot of work. It's a
lot of pain and compromise. But through that,
you achieve love and you achieve this amazing
relationship that's irreplaceable. Through those
days of suffering and doing whatever it takes to
make $250 a day, I was able to build a business
that makes a lot of money and fits my lifestyle.
I've optimized it for exactly the way I want to
live. I don't want to build, I don't want to
scale it. I don't want to have 60 employees.
I want to have four, five. I want to just keep
doing what I'm doing, just hone my skill and hone
my skill and just, I love what I do, but all of
that takes suffering and pain. I think the best
way to highlight it is art. Show me one meaningful
piece of art, cultural art that came as a result
of rainbows and butterflies and happiness, right.
Great art comes from pain, suffering, heartache,
mental illness, just terrible circumstances. Great
art comes from the darkness, not from the light,
but you need both. And if you ignore the darkness,
you will never get the light or you'll always be
chasing the light. The light will always be in
the distance, but you have to lean into the pain.
You have to — off camera, we were talking
about something else and you were saying,
I had to sit with it. And that's precisely it.
You have to sit with the pain. Don't block it
out. Don't ignore it, don't push it away. Run
into it. Run into the pain, run into the hard
stuff. Run into the stuff that nobody else wants
to do, because that's how you achieve novelty
and through novelty, you achieve everything.
Again, anybody, it doesn't matter what your
definition of success is, I can assure you that
that person is successful by whatever definition
you're holding them up to be, through novelty.
They did something that other people were afraid
to do, that other people didn't think of. Whatever
it is, it was achieved through novelty. And as far
as I can tell, all greatness is achieved
through novelty. It's doing things that
other people don't want to do, doing things that
other people are afraid to do, doing things that
other people wouldn't even think about doing. And
normally the delta between those things is pain,
suffering, heartache. It's the darkness —
Tim Ferriss: Which could take a lot of forms,
right? Like, could take the
form of being ridiculed.
Andrew Rosener: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: Right? As an example.
Absolutely. And that's just tip of
the iceberg. That's like the soft stuff. Yes.
Tim Ferriss: That's the Nerf baseball bat.
Andrew Rosener: Exactly, exactly. Once you
get through the Nerf bat, there's another guy
standing there with a real Louisville.
Tim Ferriss: So for yourself then,
because you and I think are cut from similar
cloths in a number of respects, one of which —
Andrew Rosener: Not just our bald head?
Tim Ferriss: Not just the bald head and
striking good looks, not just our resemblances
to Jason Statham, but also I think you wrestled.
Andrew Rosener: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: I know
your wrestling coach and your experience
wrestling had a huge formative impact on you.
Andrew Rosener: Huge.
Tim Ferriss: And I'm not sure
if people with high pain tolerances gravitate
to wrestling or if it cultivates it, or both.
Andrew Rosener: Chicken and the egg problem.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, chicken and the egg problem.
And there are other ways, of course, that
people develop high pain tolerances. I think
you could have childhood trauma and learn
to dissociate. I mean, I actually a lot of
people who have that experience in childhood
end up being, for instance, very high-level
military operators. A huge correlation. Don't
think that's a coincidence. And my question
is related to my own experience. I look at —
Andrew Rosener: Great entrepreneurs, by the way,
usually have daddy problems. It's another thing to
look at when you're making investments. It's like,
how's your relationship with your dad? "Oh,
it's great." "Um, okay. Meeting's over."
Tim Ferriss: That'll be round two
with Dr. Rosener. Unpacking daddy
problems for entrepreneurial success.
So the experience that I've had,
and I think I've contended with to a large extent,
but because I have a high pain tolerance and it
has been a competitive advantage, I've sometimes
ended up running towards painful things that are
not worth doing. Which it seems like it can be
a necessary cost if you are pursuing worthwhile
novelty, but just the fact that something is
painful does not justify its pursuit, right?
Andrew Rosener: Absolutely not.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm wondering for
yourself how you navigate that, because even
now, I sometimes hear the siren song. It's
tempting because I've been rewarded for that in
the past. But as I get older, I'm like, all right,
time is fleeting. I need to be more surgical about
how I approach these things, especially if I'm
trying to moderate my tendency towards anger,
which I think those two often go hand in hand.
Andrew Rosener: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: Right? So
how do you think about that?
Andrew Rosener: Simple. Very important
to have a North Star, right? So what are you
optimizing for? What do you want? Right? For me,
thanks to Charlie Tuna, I was lucky that I
learned very early on in my career, I had,
let's say, a role model, not for everything,
but for certain things about how I wanted to
live my life. I thought, wow, if you were to
ask me when I was a junior in college, like,
"Oh, what do you want to be when you grow up?"
"I want to be like a, I don't know, billionaire
tech entrepreneur with thousands of employees and
this huge company that everybody knows." And then
it was like Charlie Tuna taught me like, whoa,
that's the opposite of what you want. No, no,
no, no. Definitely, you want achieve financial
freedom, but that's just like step one. It's
like you want real freedom, you want free will.
And so I optimize for that. And so I decide,
is this worth pursuing? Is this going to help me
achieve more or less freedom in my life? Right? I
was about to build a business. We were going
to start a new company called Pegasus about,
I don't know, a year ago now, six months,
a year ago, I don't know. And we spent
six months planning this thing out,
got a CTO — we were ready to rock.
And it was in the domain business. It wasn't
like I was venturing into something totally new.
It's a business that I've never been so sure
I would've been successful in this business.
I know it would've been successful. But we got
to the one-yard line, we were about to do it,
and I asked myself, I was laying in bed and I'm
thinking to myself, so, literally tomorrow I'm
going to have this team meeting and we're going
to basically greenlight this and we're going to
start putting this in action. And that means I'm
going to hire a bunch of people and that means I'm
going to be flying all over to have meetings.
And I was like, "I don't want any of that."
There was a deep part of me that, I don't know
if imposter syndrome is the right word. I've
achieved a pretty high degree of, let's
say, financial freedom. But my business,
most of your audience would probably say my
business is garbage. Like, ah. And the reason
being is I can't scale it. I can't sell it.
Tim Ferriss: You might be surprised, but I
understand what you're saying.
Andrew Rosener: Maybe.
Tim Ferriss: But, there will be a subset.
Andrew Rosener: Totally. Traditional metrics
of let's say, what makes a good business.
My business doesn't meet that description,
but my business is amazing for me, and I
don't want it to be for somebody else. I
want it to be for me. And so I run it the
way I want to run it. And it brings me back
to a tenet of Charlie Tuna. If you pay for the
microphone, you get to say what you want to say.
Tim Ferriss: That resonates for me.
Andrew Rosener: And that comes from, I think
it was Ronald Reagan who said it in a presidential
debate. He said, or no, I think it was George
Bush, Sr. And he said, "Excuse me, but I paid for
this microphone." Somebody tried to cut him off.
Anyways, I optimize for freedom. I optimize
for freedom of deciding what to do with my
time outside of email. I optimize for being
able to live where I want to live. I optimize
for being able to move if I want to move. I
optimize for spending time with my children,
especially while they're young. I optimize
for, I eat dinner with my family every single
night at 6:30. Every single night, 6:30 with
almost zero exceptions, 6:30, I'm sitting at
the dinner table, but 6:30, I'm sitting at the
table having dinner with my kids and my wife.
I optimize to be able to, I'm going
to leave in two weeks and I'm going to
Thailand for two months, and then we're going
to bounce around, we're going to go to Laos,
we're going to go to Vietnam, and I'm going to
go explore Thailand for two months. And there
was this thing inside of me that I hadn't built a
business that I could sell. And there was this box
that I felt like I hadn't yet, and that was the
driving force for "I'm going to build Pegasus."
Pegasus is going to be — basically, we had a
clear path that we could in five to seven years,
build this into a $5 billion company. And I think
we could do it. But I got to that one-yard line,
and I ran down the checklist of the things that I
want in my life and 99 percent of the things that
I was going to get from Pegasus was the opposite
of what I wanted in my life. And so it was like,
boom. I literally went the next day. I told
everybody, I said, "I'm super sorry," but
literally, just cut the head off the Pegasus.
Right? "It's dead. This is not happening."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Got it. Okay. So that
answered my question, which was why didn't
it get spotted sooner? Right? So it was that.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah, I had this driving thing.
I had this thing, this itch that I felt like I
needed to scratch. But I think it's important,
and this is directly to your point, everybody's
got those itches that they want to scratch, but
ask yourself why. Where did that idea come from?
That idea came because that was what everybody
else wanted to do. That was the common narrative.
If you go on x.com right now, you are going to see
there's a bazillion people that are startup porn
and hustle porn. And it's like, "I haven't slept
in four days," and they're proud of it. And it's
like, no, I want seven and a half or eight hours
of sleep every night. I'm optimizing for that.
And granted, in the early days of starting the
business, there's a lot of nights that
I'm not getting that and there's a lot
of suffering and a lot of pain. But I was able
to suffer through the pain and the hardship and
the extraordinary hours and the blah, blah,
blah, blah. Because I had this North Star,
I knew that there was a light at the end of the
tunnel. And that light wasn't some ambiguous goal
that somebody else gave me. It was actually
what I wanted. It was actually what Charlie
Tuna had taught me about how I wanted to live my
life. I wanted to be free. I wanted to be able
to not answer to anybody for anything, except my
wife, and literally just live my life as I choose.
If you inspired me right now with some idea
that achieve some of these things that I want
in my life, close business tomorrow, or let the
guys run it and guys, I'm out and I don't know,
go live in the Amazon. I want that optionality,
even if I'm never going to take it. I want that
optionality at all times. And I don't ever want
to feel like I have to make a decision because
of somebody else's —
Tim Ferriss: Agenda.
Andrew Rosener: Agenda.
Tim Ferriss: Priorities.
Andrew Rosener: Exactly. Exactly.
So I hyper-optimize for that.
Tim Ferriss: Thank God for Charlie Tuna, huh?
Andrew Rosener: Thank God for Charlie Tuna,
really. Actually, if I were to say the
three most important influences in my life,
it would be wrestling from an early age. I started
at five, and this is hilarious, because literally
our coach, salute Wayne Griffin, one of the
top wrestling coaches in America. It's not,
say, in Ohio or Pennsylvania. He used to write
in marker across our forehead or in a meet,
he'd write it across our headgear, "Pain is
temporary, pride is forever." And I guess
that stuck with me. It started at an early age.
And then I was very lucky. My parents really
modeled for me, I want to say this because
I think it's also one of the elements that
defines success for me is it's also super
pertinent to what we're saying. My parents have
been married 40 years, 50, 50 years, 50 years, 50
something, 52. And I think that a long-enduring,
mostly loving marriage is one of the most
underrated elements of success in the world.
Maybe the most underrated. I am self-destructive.
If it wasn't for my wife, man, it's a binary
outcome. I'm either dead or I don't know,
eccentric billionaire doing things that don't
represent any of the things I've just described
to you as what I actually want in my life.
Tim Ferriss: Howard Hughes
putting his urine in milk bottles.
Andrew Rosener: A hundred percent. A hundred
percent. I'm going to save you that story.
Tim Ferriss: Round two. Daddy
issues and urine-drinking.
Andrew Rosener: It certainly wasn't easy, but they
modeled for me what were the minimum requirements
to have an enduring relationship. And so that was
really important. And then Charlie Tuna. Charlie
Tuna really just took it away, and, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: What a fucking crazy story,
man. Your life is amazing. It's so wild.
Andrew Rosener: Every day, I really believe
I have the best job in the world because every day
I'm engaging with just super interesting people.
Tim Ferriss: You and I have
different paths to the same thing.
Andrew Rosener: Yes, a hundred percent. A hundred
percent. That's why you resonated with me from
the get-go, man — what an amazing path to
just engage with these high performers and
you get to hear a lot more of their stories.
I don't get to ask a lot of questions, but —
Tim Ferriss: Although you get to have
off-the-record conversations about money,
and I remember someone said to me, they were
like, "If you really want to know somebody,
you've got to talk to them about their
finances and sex." And they're like,
"You will know everything about that person."
Andrew Rosener: Yeah, sounds like an idea
for a new podcast.
Tim Ferriss: I'm
having public conversations. So you get a very
different side. You get the behind-the-scenes,
which is also super interesting.
Andrew Rosener: Not all the time,
but yes. I mean, again, I'm an extremely
discreet person. Privacy is kind of like —
Tim Ferriss: It has to be. It has
to be a religion for you guys.
So we're going to wind to a close, get you to
dinner with your family, get me to dinner with
my team. Is there anything you'd like to
say before we close up shop for the day?
Andrew Rosener: Thank you. It was really
an honor to sit down with you. I really
cherish it. I've taken a tremendous amount of
wisdom from you and your guests over the years,
and so it's a bit surreal to be sitting on
this side of the microphone. But, thank you.
Tim Ferriss: You're welcome. My pleasure.
Andrew Rosener: Thank you for all that
you do, really.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah,
thanks man. And I remember since our first
meeting, we were talking about these Hokkaido
scallops. I was like, "All right, there may be a
point in time when we have to have a conversation
in front of some mics," and it happened.
Andrew Rosener: Even when I was young,
my sister and I learned Japanese when I was
probably between 10 and 13. A couple days a
week we went to this woman's house and she would
teach us origami and how to cook and speaking
Japanese. But I've lost all of it. So I'd be
embarrassed to try. I think I can count to eight
is about the extent of my Japanese these days.
Tim Ferriss: Well, you have that optionality.
So tomorrow you could close up shop and become a
Buddhist monk in the mountains of Japan.
Andrew Rosener: That might be next year.
Tim Ferriss: If you wanted, if you wanted.
All right. So just to recap where people can
find you, mediaoptions.com.
Andrew Rosener: Correct.
Tim Ferriss: The industry's leading educational
podcast, DomainSherpa, which people can find at
domainsherpa.com and on Twitter —
Andrew Rosener: Ds.tv will take
you to the YouTube channel.
Tim Ferriss: Ds.tv goes to the
YouTube channel and @AndrewRosener on Twitter.
And we'll include also additional tenets of
Charlie Tuna and so on in the show notes.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah, they are priceless
and they should be in time, immemorial.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So we will put those as always
at tim.blog/podcast and people can find this and
to everybody listening, thanks for tuning in.
As always, be a little kinder than necessary to
others and to yourself. Until next time, thanks so
much for listening to The Tim Ferriss Show.
***
Andrew Rosener: When I said "hunting bigger
fish," I mean it quite literally in the sense
that I said before, people were knocking on my
door to have me sell their domain names. And now
as opposed to trying to go solicit and sell these
$5,000 domains, $20,000 domains, $50,000 domains,
I said, "I want to go contact the owners of some
of these bigger domains and pitch them on having
me go sell these domains to an end-user." And in
order to do that, I had to have some semblance
of an idea of what I thought their domain
is worth. Because whether you're contacting
a buyer or seller, the first question, "What's
the price? What are you going to sell it for?
What are you trying to sell it for?" And so —
Tim Ferriss: Scallops, houses, doesn't matter.
Andrew Rosener: Doesn't matter. What's the
price? And so I had to do a lot of thinking
about what am I going to tell them? And I'm
not going to lie, there was a lot of fake it
until you make it in the early days.
Tim Ferriss: $1 billion dollars.
Andrew Rosener: A hundred percent.
Tim Ferriss: I have some bad news, Bob. I
didn't get the billion. Here's the good news.
Andrew Rosener: There's a certain degree of
also telling these people what they
wanted to hear because I didn't have
a reputation at that point, or not much
of one. I didn't have a lot to write off.
Tim Ferriss: Bob, you may have heard of
pizza.net. All right, sorry. Keep going.
Andrew Rosener: No, no. So the absurdity
is not lost. So at that time, well,
you're sort of a soft master of this. In that
early 2000s, mid-2000s, SEO was really the
name of the game for online marketing. That was
where people were really making the real money,
and most people were guessing on it. But there
was a few good people that really knew how to
play the game. And I got very lucky, I'm not
going to say his name because he's one of my
favorite people in the world. He's one of the just
truly an amazing, amazing, one of the most humble
and just incredibly intelligent, and just by my
definition, one of the most successful people I
can think of. But he's very private, so I won't
say his name, but I was lucky enough to get him as
a client and he basically said, look — he hired me
to actually go buy domains for him as opposed to
what I had been doing, which was outbound selling.
And the domains he wanted to buy and the prices
he was willing to pay for them were shocking to
me and I couldn't understand it. And I'm a very
curious person. And so I was really like — I
pride myself, I don't ask too many questions
of my clients. And I think that that's one
of the things that they appreciate. But when
the opportunity arises, I try to get into their
head and understand how they see these things,
particularly as it pertains to domains and
other things that are pertinent to me. So
I got to understand the way he saw domain names,
and I realized that even though he didn't know it
at the time, it was literally the key to creating
an objective valuation for any domain name. And I
had to tie it back to a way that people in
business could understand to create a business
case for — because people just flat out reject
you because these domains are expensive. And if
I'm soliciting them, they weren't planning
to spend this money to buy this domain.
So it's just very easy to just say no. So I have
to have a very compelling business case as to why
they should spend this money to buy this domain.
And this took quite some time, and I guess this
is one of the reasons for my success was again,
I'm not afraid to just throw things against the
wall. And so I would start formulating these
sort of algorithms or too strong of a word and
make me sound more clever than I am. But these
formulas of how I could think about and how I
could demonstrate to somebody what this domain was
worth in an objective way. It was based on data
that couldn't be negated. This wasn't an emotional
thing. This wasn't a intangible thing. It was
like, "Look, let's think about what is the purpose
of a domain name." And the purpose of a domain
name is to connect a business or an idea with
its intended customer or reader. Many different
use cases on the internet. Let's stick with
business for now. So connecting a business, its
product and services with an intended customer.
And you can do that with an IP address, which is
ultimately what a domain name is masking. Okay,
it's an IP address, but humans aren't very good
at remembering long strings of random numbers. And
so that was really the point of creating a domain
name. And so if we think about a domain name from
that first principle of domains exist because it's
a human, readable format for getting somebody
on the internet to a destination, then what are
the characteristics of the domain name that might
make it more valuable than another one? Okay. And
I thought about it from a business perspective.
I said, "Okay, if I'm going to create a startup,
I'm looking at it from a perspective of what's
my total addressable market? How big can this
business be?" And I believe, it's my thesis,
which has seemingly proven true over hundreds
of millions of sales and many years now, is that
you can measure the total addressable market. The
objective, not necessarily subjective, but the
objective addressable market of a domain name can
be measured through starting with search volume.
So you can go to Google or any of these SEO tools
and you can say, "Okay, how many people a month
are searching for car insurance?" Just the words:
car insurance. And then there's an associated long
tail with that car insurance in Phoenix, Arizona,
new car insurance, used car insurance.
Tim Ferriss: Best car insurance.
Andrew Rosener: Best car insurance, right. Car
insurance quotes. So there's a whole long tail
associated with that. And each of those
long tails is discounted to some extent,
but primarily we're looking at the core exact
match search volume for a particular keyword
or acronym. And that's going to give us the total
addressable market in the United States, globally,
whatever country. You can usually break these
things down by country and see where is this
market. And then you can see what is that market
worth by looking at what are advertisers willing
to pay for that keyword. There's a certain amount
of traffic going to Google searching for that.
Now, for simplicity's sake, I'm focusing on Google
here because it's the one that people are going to
resonate with the most, but we extrapolated —
Not immediately, but over the years,
we've extrapolated this out to basically
measuring use in culture and use in commerce,
which can be measured on social media, which can
be measured on YouTube, which can be measured
across a whole frame of different metrics. But for
the purpose of simplicity, we were measuring how
many people are searching Google for this keyword
or acronym? What are advertisers willing to pay
for that keyword or acronym? And that's going to
give you, just those two numbers alone is going
to tell you what's the total addressable market
on a monthly basis for that keyword or acronym
objectively. And then you can extrapolate that
out by a reasonable business multiple and say,
"Okay, well this total market is worth, I don't
know, conservatively, let's say 36 months." In
some other industries, maybe it's 60 months. In
some other industries, it might be 120 months.
Tim Ferriss: Can you explain that for a second?
I'm from Long Island. A little slow on the uptake
sometimes. So explain how the time varies.
Andrew Rosener:
Okay, so each business or industry —
Tim Ferriss: Or duration, so to speak.
Andrew Rosener: Each business or industry, if
you're looking at M&A, one business is going to
buy another business, there's generally a multiple
that these people will pay. In each industry,
it varies. And the type of business varies.
Tim Ferriss: I see what you're saying. So the
multiples is dependent on which industry
the search term is associated with.
Andrew Rosener: Right. How
durable is this business?
Tim Ferriss: I got it, I got it. So if
it's retail versus SaaS versus whatever.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. If it's some sort of the
hot, new shiny object trend, you're going to
put a pretty low multiple on it. It might be
two years, three years. If it's, I don't know,
cabinets.com, okay. It might be a very long
multiple because it's a very durable industry.
It's not going to be a lot of disruption, and the
multiple's going to generally be a bit higher.
Tim Ferriss: I see. I wasn't thinking about
this correctly. So the durability is a real
factor in this particular calculation. It's
not just looking at the industry and what
type of acquisition prices —
Andrew Rosener: It's both.
Tim Ferriss: Right. It's a
combination of those, totally.
Andrew Rosener: And again, this comes back to
meeting people where they are. So I generally
will not presume, and I'll ask them, "If you were
buying a business in your industry, what's the
multiple you'd be looking to pay?" And that's the
number that I'll use. And most people are — they
know that off the top of their head, like,
"Generally, we pay 3X, 5X." So when I'm doing
back of the napkin, I generally use three because
I like to just be conservative, and I find that to
be the best approach with domain names. Because
as you said, most people don't understand how to
value these things. So the more conservative
you are, the more you're going to resonate.
So you multiply that out, you got how many people
search per month. Okay, let's just call it use in
commerce and culture. We can measure that. What
are people willing to pay for that traffic? We
can measure that, multiply those two, and then
extrapolate out by the number of months that is
appropriate for that industry or business. That's
going to tell you basically, roughly speaking,
there's other variables, but that's going
to tell you your total addressable market.
We're going to look at click-through rate and
conversion rate. And so that's the next part
of the formula is here's the total addressable
market, and here's the amount of that market I
feel like I can realistically capture. And this
is where sort of the SEO comes in. So if you are
ranking number one in Google for a particular
keyword, and it varies based on keyword,
and you're the number one organic listing,
meaning you're not paying Google to be number one,
you're organically ranking, you can reasonably
expect somewhere in the 25 percent call. It
used to be 28, maybe it's 23, maybe it's 18,
but it's 20, 28 percent click-through rate
just for being the organic first listing of that.
Okay, so let's just say roughly speaking, there's
a hundred thousand people a month searching for
this keyword. 28 percent of those paid, let's say
25 free easy numbers because I'm doing public
math, which is generally a rule I have against
doing, but 25 percent of those people are going
to click. So now you've got 25 thousand people
that are going to come to your website, and how
many of those people are you going to reasonably
convert? And I like to use two percent. I think
it's generally a conservative e-commerce metric,
two to four percent, but let's say two percent.
So you're going to have about 500 people per month
that are converting. And then you multiply that
by whatever you would have been. It's basically
the opportunity cost. So what would you have been
paying Google to get that? Okay. And that's going
to tell you the cost of customer acquisition
to be that number one position in Google.
And then based on a bunch of studies from
Microsoft, and we can reference those studies
in your show notes if you want, but you can
demonstrate what the delta is between having
a domain name that clearly — it needs to be
one of two things. It needs to be a brand that
people trust and/or recognize. Or it needs to
have clear intent baked in. So the domain name
needs to match the intent of the user. And if you
have those two things, you're going to materially
increase — I don't remember the exact number
offhand, but it's a very material increase in
the conversion rate and the click-through rate,
both. So using that formula, we can demonstrate
very clearly the delta between your cost of
customer acquisition on joeysbagofdonuts.com
versus donuts.com. You're going to have the
higher click-through rate, which is going
to give you the bigger opportunity, and then
you're going to have a higher conversion rate,
which is going to obviously grow your business.
And so that delta extrapolated out by whatever
that reasonable business multiple is the objective
value of the domain name. Does that make sense?
Tim Ferriss: It does make sense. I think
I'd probably need to see it on paper.
Andrew Rosener: So ultimately, we're
taking it back to that first principle,
which is a domain name’ss value is its ability to
arbitrage your cost of customer acquisition. If we
can reduce your cost of customer acquisition with
this domain name, there's a value. And then you
just have to multiply that value out by however
long you feel is appropriate for your business
to tell you what is this domain name worth
to your business. And that is a non-trivial,
non-objectionable business case that ultimately
is what led to my success in this business was I
was able to make a business case and convert
people where others failed. Because it was a
mathematical valuation methodology that nobody
had ever seen before. And you could say, "Look,
how can you say no? I'm showing you how I'm going
to reduce your cost of customer acquisition, which
is one of the most important metrics any business
is going to measure. And so if I can do that, how
many months multiple are you willing to pay me?"
Tim Ferriss: I guess, the months multiple is
where it seems like you could have a disagreement.
Andrew Rosener: Sure, absolutely. And that's where
the disagreement lies. But it certainly doesn't
have a hundred percent hit rate. Most people
still have an emotional block to, "I'm not going
to pay some domain squatters X amount of money
for this domain name." It's just an emotional
wall. And sometimes I can break through that and
sometimes I can't. Over long periods of time, I'm
generally pretty good at converting people. But
once it clicks for people that there is a material
reduction in the cost of a customer acquisition,
I don't need closed deal on that day. It's like
the movie Inception, the Leonardo DiCaprio movie.
Once I've planted the seed in your mind, you're
going to go home and you're going to go to bed,
you're going to have board meetings,
you're going to meet with your founders,
you're going to meet with teams in your company,
and at some point it's going to come up and you're
going to wake up one morning with this moment
of inception where you think it's your idea that
you're going to be able to scale your business
in a way that you otherwise wouldn't be able to.
You're going to launch a new division, you're
going to start buying paid advertising. Some
initiative is going to benefit tremendously by
owning this domain name. Maybe a new competitor
has launched. Maybe there's somebody with
your brand name in a different industry that
you don't want them to have the domain,
but something is going to pop. There's
going to come a moment — which is why domain
names are generally a very long sales cycle,
but there's going to be an inception point
where you wake up one morning and you think,
"Okay, now I need this domain name." And then
you're going to call me back, or you're going to
send me an email and you're going to say, "Hey, is
that domain still available?" And sometimes it is,
sometimes it's not. Another sort of
powerful phrase that we've coined is off
the market forever. Once these things sell,
they're generally off the market forever.
The moment a company makes a decision to acquire
this domain name that they were fighting tooth
and nail not to buy previously, it's basically
priceless to them. Because what they then say,
which is so interesting to me because they don't
realize it before buying it, is that they then
say, "But this is my brand." And you go, well, "I
couldn't agree more, but then why didn't you want
to buy it in the first place?" But the moment
a company buys it, the first thing they'll tell
you is, "This is my brand. I can't sell it."
I won't use this specific example, but we sold
the domain. It was quite a good price, but I was
fighting tooth and nail. Nobody wanted to buy this
domain. It was a very good domain. The price was
very good. It was $250,000 for a domain that I
would tell you was worth at least double, triple
that. And we finally sold it. And immediately,
literally 24 hours later, I would say the David
versus the Goliath, the David shows up and says,
"You know what? I made a mistake. I want to buy
it." And said, "I just sold it." And so this guy
was really, really successful, but he was
like a ninja versus a big Goliath. He was
like the Charlie Tuna versus the big factory.
But he had a really successful business and he
had some money. And he said, "Look, offer them..."
I think it was — like the example, I think it was
a hundred thousand dollars more. Owner said no.
And this guy had just bought it. He hadn't done
a single thing with the domain name. It literally
hit his account 24 hours ago. He hasn't set up an
email on it. He hasn't even redirected the domain
name. It's got a parking page on it, nothing,
zero. He just is now the owner. And we went from
— he bought it for 250. This guy offered 350. He
said no. Went to 500. He said no. Went to 750.
He said no. Went to $1 million. He said no. That
guy tapped out. And this guy was just like, "I
don't think there's a price. It would basically
be he'd have to buy my whole business for me
to sell this domain because this is my brand."
And it's a very strange phenomena where
people don't — they don't make that click
before buying the domain. And the moment they
own it, they realize how powerful this is for
their brand. It's the most important
asset in many cases, not in all cases,
but in many cases it's much more valuable and much
more powerful than their trademark itself. Because
he who has the dot com, there's only one. And so
Apple wouldn't be — if it was Applecomputer.com,
they couldn't run around calling themselves Apple
because somebody else would own Apple. And they
would be Apple because the dot com is ingrained
into people's brains with trillions and trillions
and trillions of dollars in advertising since
1985 when the first domain name was registered.
It is just an endless — every sports game
has domain names pasted around the arena.
Every news channel, you're getting inundated
with dot coms, every big brand that you know,
it is just ingrained. It's assumed. And
so if you are anything except your exact
brand match dot com, you cannot or should
not refer to yourself as your, let's say,
raw brand. If you're dot net or dot io or dot
AI even, I would argue, and you're not calling
yourself — let's say you're, I'll use Dharmesh
because he's a good sport. Dharmesh from HubSpot.
He has agent.ai. It's a new little venture that
he's launched. And you can't call yourself Agent
unless you've got agent.com, because —
Tim Ferriss: Why not? Just to —
Andrew Rosener: Because people are going to
assume you're dot com. If you're agent.ai,
then your brand is agent.ai. And if you refer to
yourself as anything else, at a minimum, you're
going to lose 10 percent of your traffic. This
has been done. The best study is from Overstock.
Overstock tried to do a rebrand to o.co. That's
a whole super phenomenal, interesting story that
comes back to the one letter dot coms and whatnot.
But anyways, they tried to do a rebrand to o.co,
and they were obsessed with this, and they'd
made an enormous campaign, and they did massive
branding, massive advertising to promote this
rebrand. And they immediately — I don't remember,
I think it was like six months, maybe less, they
immediately pivoted back to overstock.com because
what they saw was that they were losing,
I think it was 40 percent, it's like 30 to
40 percent of all their traffic was getting lost.
Tim Ferriss: And why didn't they just redirect
Overstock.com to o.co? Is that a dumb question?
Andrew Rosener: Well, no, the point was that
they're out there advertising themselves as
Overstock is now O, but then people type in o.com.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I see what you're
saying. I see what you mean.
Andrew Rosener: And so then it's a dead website.
So what does that say about your brand. Like, "Oh,
I am on a 404 page, or I'm on a dead
— this domain doesn't resolve page."
This domain doesn't resolve, so it's
very detrimental to your brand. I think
Amazon highlights this best. I don't know
what the increase in conversion rate was,
but like just by taking away one step
and making the one click purchase had
a profound impact on conversion for Amazon.
Tim Ferriss: Say that one more time please.
Andrew Rosener: When Amazon
introduced the one click purchasing —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, sure.
Andrew Rosener: — it had a profound impact.
I remember at the time they were talking about
it like these very small — if you can remove just
even very small incremental elements of friction
between your customer in their journey to close,
every small bit of friction that you can remove
you're materially increasing your conversion rate,
and obviously top line and bottom line.
Tim Ferriss: As demonstrated by the number
of Amazon boxes that arrive based on my 3:00 AM
orders that I think are 100 percent important and
critical to my lifestyle. So ultimately that's
what a domain does. That's why Amazon bought
prime.com, because when I use prime.com, like
every time I want to watch something on Prime I go
to prime.com. I don't go to Amazon and then click
on Prime, and then go to Prime video. Like there's
five steps there. Instead I just hit prime.com.
Tim Ferriss: You know, this is my one opportunity
to share I think the only domain trivia that I
have with someone who knows domain a thousand
times better than I do, and I'm sure you
know this already, but do you know which
.com forwards to amazon.com that —
Andrew Rosener: I know a lot
of them. I sold most of them to them.
Tim Ferriss: Did you sell relentless.com?
Andrew Rosener: No. No Relentless was actually
going to be the original name for Amazon. That
was Jeff Bezos' original domain name for the
venture actually before pivoting to Amazon.
Yeah. But Jeff loves domain names.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sure.
Andrew Rosener: When he was running the company,
when he was still CEO, they bought a lot of
domain names. We sold them a lot of domain
names, and very strategic and very smart,
he understood domain names in a very profound way
that most other business executives don't. And I
can tell you that with quite a strong basis
because I literally have done business with
virtually all of them, all of the big companies,
and very few understand how a domain name can
solve that customer journey the way that Jeff did.
And he utilized a lot of those domains. He was way
ahead of the curve. He bought podcast.com,
which forwards now to Audible. He bought
author.com, prime.com, tube.com.
Tim Ferriss: He's a smart man.
Andrew Rosener: Yeah. Very. A very smart guy.
Tim Ferriss: Very ahead of the curve.